Ja, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 51. Wir sind heute zu Gast an einem Ort, wo wir schon mal waren, nämlich dem deutschen Fusionsplasma-Experiment im Wendelstein 7X, ist das korrekt? genau und stellt euch doch mal kurz vor.
Ja, ich bin Thomas Klinge und seit 17 Jahren kümmere ich mich um den bau dieser Maschine und sie ist jetzt fertig und jetzt habe ich eine ähnliche Rolle, nämlich jetzt geht es um den Betrieb der Maschine und da versuche ich dafür zu sorgen, dass hier vernünftig geforscht werden kann.
Ich bin Adrian von Stecher. Ich glaube, das letzte Mal, als ich hier war, war ich gerade so frisch promoviert wahrscheinlich. Zwischendurch bin ich hier festangestellt und bin Physiker, Diagnostiker, Turbulenzforscher, arbeite direkt am Experiment dann auch.
Wir haben tatsächlich eine Menge Wünsche von Hörern gekriegt, nochmal hier vorbeizukommen. Die letzte Folge war auch eine unserer erfolgreichsten von den zuschauerzahlen her. Und das bewegt die Leute natürlich heute sogar noch mehr als letztes Mal, weil wir jetzt eben mit dem Klimawandel noch so ein bisschen akuter ein Problemgefühl haben. Und das ist eigentlich auch die erste Frage, die wir hier stellen wollten. So was ist denn, wenn jetzt hier Bill Gates kommt oder irgendjemand mit einem großen Geldbeutel und sagt, wir brauchen ein Fusionskraftwerk bis 2035. So, ginge das? Ja, wir haben letztes Mal ähnliche Fragen gehabt und da war die Antwort, ich hab gestern extra nochmal nachgehört, war die Antwort, ja, also wenn man kühn wäre, könnte man jetzt einfach anfangen. Aber es hat irgendwie keiner angefangen, oder?
Es war niemand kühl.
Ja, an der Aussage ändert sich nix. Am Ende ist es eine Frage, wie viel Risiko man nehmen will und ich rede da nicht von Gesundheitsrisiko oder Betriebsrisiko, sondern am Ende, welches finanzielle Risiko man nehmen will. Im Prinzip könnte man jetzt schon etwas bauen, aber es ist nicht gesichert, dass das gut und zuverlässig geht. In dem Sinne ist es dann für einen Investor erstmal nüchtern betrachtet, nicht besonders attraktiv, weil man etwas investiert, das wäre also first of the kind, also das erste Mal realisiert. Man kann nicht mit guten Gewissen sagen, das läuft. Das kann auch einfach nicht gut werden. Also unzuverlässig sein, unwirtschaftlich sein etc. Das ist erstmal vom grundsätzlichen Investitionsschema keine so tolle Sache. Dafür dient ja die ganze Forschung, eine wissenschaftliche und technische Basis herzustellen, sozusagen so einen festen Grund zu schaffen, dass dann die Wirtschaft sagen kann, okay, jetzt ist die Sache gut verstanden genug und hat eine solide Basis, dass man da investieren kann. Dann ist das wirtschaftlich sinnvoll. Dann gibt es auch wieder einen Geldrückfluss irgendwann einmal.
Das letzte Mal als wir hier waren, wart ihr ja gerade so, hattet ihr, glaube ich, gerade so stabiles Plasma zum ersten Mal? Oder wart kurz davor oder kurz danach?
Über mir war das ein Sekundenstabil.
Das war sozusagen der große Meilenstein, so stabiles Plasma. Was ist denn seitdem passiert in den letzten sieben Jahren?
Oh Gott, da können wir jetzt eine Stunde drüber reden.
Los, wir wollen es gleich noch machen.
Deswegen sind wir hier.
Dann war das eine Frage und eine Antwort. Aber wir steigen da gerne mal ein. Ich fange einfach mal an. Ganz grundsätzlich ist enorm viel passiert. Wir hatten auch noch eine sehr lange bauphase. Die sich über mehr als drei Jahre erstreckt hat, wo gar nicht geforscht, sondern gebaut wurde. Und diese bauphase, die war wirklich schwierig. Die war sehr hart. Da können wir uns noch ein bisschen drunter halten. Das ist jetzt mal so ein Teaser. Und jetzt ist die Maschine eigentlich komplett. Das heißt jetzt alles beisammen, dass wir tatsächlich bei hoher Heizleistung, also das heißt bei hoher Energie, die wir reinstecken zur Erzeugung des Plasmas, dieses Plasma sehr lange betreiben können. Und das ist so das spezifizierte Ziel, halbe Stunde. Das ist ein bisschen willkürlich. Man hätte auch eine Stunde sagen können oder eine Viertelstunde, aber irgendwo muss man sich festlegen. Eine halbe Stunde bei 10 Megawatt Mikrowellenleistung, die man da reinsteckt. Und das multipliziert sich dann hoch, wenn man also die Sekunden mit der Leistung multipliziert. Das sind dann die berühmten 18 Gigajoule. Das ergibt sich aus der Multiplikation aus Leistung und Zeit. Energie ist Leistung und Zeit. Und da sind wir noch nicht. Wir haben jetzt das eine Gigajoule gerade überschritten. Das war schon ein großer Meilenstein. Ich muss sagen, das war schon so ruhig. Da macht man so einen Plus mal ein paar Minuten an. Unsere Fälle waren so acht Minuten.
Ja, aber das ist doch schon...
Ja, und dabei geht man sich schon zu langweilen. Ja.
Ich weiß noch, als wir diese langen Pulse zum ersten Mal wirklich getestet haben und da auch zuversichtlich waren, dass wir es schaffen, ohne dass Komponenten überhitzen und die nötigen Diagnostiken dazu auch bereit waren, war natürlich kurz Aufregung, auch über diverse Telegram-Gruppen in die Büros geschrieben, jetzt geht es los, jetzt geht es los. Dann kamen irgendwie alle rüber und dann guckt man auf den Schirm, aber nach zwei, drei Minuten passiert halt nichts.
Ja, aber das ist doch gut.
Das ist ja auch gut, genau. Das ist langweilig, es ist gut, dass wir einen Generator haben, der sich benimmt, der jetzt nicht irgendwie komische Instabilitäten entwickelt oder im Seltsam davon rennt nach ein paar Minuten Betrieb. genau so wollten wir das auch und wir haben gesehen, dass grundsätzlich es keine großen Showstopper gibt, die uns jetzt daran hindern, jetzt zu noch längeren Betriebszeiten zu gehen.
Wobei, also das ist ja auch ein bisschen in die Presse gegangen mit den 8 Nuten und Gigajoule und so was. Das haben wir natürlich auch der Öffentlichkeit mitgeteilt, gehört ja auch mit zu unserer Pflicht. Also die ganz große Würde war das noch nicht. Nämlich, wie ich ja schon eben gesagt habe, im Prinzip ist alles auf 10 Megawatt ausgelegt, 10 Megawatt Mikrowellenleistung und dann zieht man die Zeit lang. Jedes 10 Megawatt mal Zeit, das ergibt dann immer die Gigajoule oder 1,5 Megajoule, 1 Gigajoule. Jetzt haben wir uns bei der Leistung noch ein bisschen zurückgehalten, sind dann noch relativ moderat geblieben und haben dann die Zeit lang gezogen. So kann man dann auch die Gigajoule erzeugen. Aber die hohe Kunst ist natürlich bei der vollen Leistung, denn die langen Zeiten zu machen. Das heißt, wir müssen länger, wir müssen höher, sozusagen mehr, also höher weiter wie nach dem olympischen Motto.
Und was sind so die Probleme, die wesentlichen Hürden?
Ein ganzer strauß.
Also ihr hättet nicht einfach weiterlaufen müssen können.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das ist ganz heikel. Wir haben jetzt ja gerade die technischen voraussetzungen geschaffen, dass wir die gesamte Wand, wenn ich Wand sage, meine ich die Wand, die im thermischen Kontakt mit dem Plasma steht, denn so ein Plasma trägt ja Wärme, wir stecken Energie rein, die geht als Wärme wieder raus letztlich, dass diese Wand komplett wassergekühlt ist. Das war dieser Riesenakt, da haben wir über drei Jahre dran gebaut. Das ist die basisvoraussetzung dafür, dass wir eine wassergekühlte Wand haben, sonst kriegen wir die Wärme nicht raus, die wir reinstecken. Und dann wird die Wand irgendwann heiß und da muss man eine Stunde warten, bis sie sich abgekühlt hat. Dadurch, dass sie jetzt aktiv im Wasser gekühlt ist, muss man nicht mehr warten, sondern man kann daraus einen kontinuierlichen Prozess machen. Also die basisvoraussetzung war, dann kommt ein ganzer strauß weiteres dazu. Dann muss unsere IT im weitesten Sinne, also unsere gesamte Datenakquisition, Steuerung, die Visualisierung, das Verarbeiten der Daten muss dafür ausgelegt sein, für solche langen dauer. Und das ist ein Unterschied, ob man etwas eine Sekunde oder zehn Sekunden verarbeiten kann oder eine halbe Stunde lang. Das sind andere Welten, auch von den Datenmengen her, auch von der Komplexität der gesamten informatikaufgabe. Dann müssen die Beobachtungsinstrumente, Adiagentinstrumenten, die Instrumente von allen anderen, wir haben insgesamt so 70 Instrumente etwa, die müssen alle dafür ausgelegt sein. Also die müssen erstens es aushalten, die müssen die Wärmeflüsse und auch die restlichen Mikrowellen, die dort rumgeistern, wir reden davon Streustrahlung, das müssen die alles aushalten und zwar nicht für ein paar Sekunden aushalten, sondern eben halt für Minuten, zig Minuten aushalten. Das ist jeweils immer eine ganz andere Welt. Also insofern sind wir da technologisch jetzt in einem völlig neuen, neuen Bereich und den in der Konsequenz auch noch keiner gemacht hat. Da sind wir jetzt Pioniere und tasten uns da in eine seltsame neue Welt vor.
Ich glaube, man unterschätzt das auch immer. Also ich hab das auch unterschätzt. Das sind am Ende von den Leistungsdichten, die auf die Komponenten auftreffen, ist das immer gar nicht so viel. Aber die Dinge stehen halt im Vakuum rum. Also die kühlen ja nicht ab, wenn sie keinen guten thermischen Kontakt oder keine gute Kühlung haben. Das heißt, so ein Klotz Grafit, der da einfach so rum sitzt, der kriegt dann seine 20, 30, 50 Watt ab. Das ist ja nichts. Aber nach einer halben Stunde ist er dann irgendwie anderthalbtausend Grad heiß. Geht dann irgendwann, also fängt an weiß zu glühen. Man kann sich dann überlegen, wie viel Wärme man über Strahlung verliert und man die Dinge auch einfach strahlen lässt. Aber ja, da geht halt sehr viel Engineering rein. Sehr viel Überlegung, was kann man denn zulassen? Wie viel dürfen meine Komponenten aushalten? Ist das für die Maschine schädlich? Und dazu schon vom technischen Aufwand einfach die Maschine so zusammenzusetzen, dass sie so lange laufen kann. Also abgesehen von der ganzen Physik, der Plasma-Physik, sondern einfach nur den Wärmelasten und im Vakuum was zu betreiben für so lange. Schon gar nicht so einfach.
Ich habe nämlich an deinem begeistertes Gesicht als deine Düse geglüht.
Ich war nicht so begeistert.
Da saß er aber ganz unentspannt.
Ja, das glaube ich. Was man vielleicht auch nochmal erklären muss, das ist so ein bisschen wie raumschiffbau. Ja, wir haben hier drei Komponenten ineinander und da kann man nicht mal eben reinlaufen. Die in der Mitte ist super kalt. Die kann auch nicht mal eben auftauen, sondern das dauert dann irgendwie Wochen.
Also, die in der Mitte ist heiß und dann kommt kalt.
Ja, ich meinte die zwischen der Außen und der Innen, die ist halt kalt. Steigen denn die Probleme linear mit der Mikrowelleneistung oder wird das schneller, schlimmer oder weniger schlimmer? Das kann auch sein.
Naja, das Prinzip der Linearität, das ist dort nur eingeschränkt anwendbar. Also, viel dominanter ist eigentlich dieser Kettenprinzip. Also, das schwächste Glied der Kette bestimmt, ob die Kette reißt. Also, das heißt also, ein ganz kleines bauteil, was man übersehen hat, was ungekühlt ist, wenn das anfängt zu glühen oder zu heiß zu werden und damit auch Dreck zu imitieren. Also, das heißt, so Materie beginnt dann ja, beginnt die Atome rauszuschmeißen. Diese Atome, die killen dann letztlich das Plasma, weil die dann ins Plasma hineinwandern, dann wie ein christbaum, fängt das ganze Plasma wie ein christbaum zu leuchten, kühlt sich ab und kollabiert dann eventuell. Dann ist sowieso gleich Ende, bei der ganzen Angelegenheit. Und wenn da anfängt, was runterzutropfen, dann ist auch nicht gut. Also, das heißt, ja, manchmal kann man das tragen. Also, wir erzählen vielleicht auch noch eine Anekdote, keine Ahnung. Aber auf jeden Fall, das Schwächste liegt der Kette bestimmt, wie die Kette steht, also wie stabil die Kette ist. Also, insofern muss man da unheimlich viel Detailarbeit machen. Und 20-mal durch alles durchkämmen, haben wir noch etwas vergessen zu kühlen. Und da mussten wir endlos viele Design Reviews durchführen. Das ist so ein formaler Prozess. Dann viele Augen drauf gucken. Und genau diese Überprüfung, der noch mal machen, haben wir etwas übersehen. Wie ist das gelöst? Ist das überzeugend? Das wird dann alles dokumentiert und implementiert und dann noch mal geprüft. Und dann gibt es ja noch einen Design Review und dann gibt es noch einen 3. Design Review. Drei Stück sind bei uns vorgeschrieben. Und da mussten wir uns komplett einmal durchkämpfen durch diese ganze Bewertung auch des Ganzen. Am Ende ist das dann so, ja, wenn es erst mal gekühlt ist, ist es gut. Also wenn das richtig ausgelegt ist, dann braucht man sich darum keine Sorgen machen. Wie gesagt, Linearität, also das, damit kann ich das mal zusammen anfangen. Es ist einfach erst mal ganz anders. Also das heißt, wassergekühlte Komponenten sind anders. Die müssen anders technisch dimensioniert werden. Die verhalten sich anders und die sind da auch im Betrieb anders zu bewerten.
Also gestern, als wir die Anlänge nochmal angeguckt haben, fiel ja schon auf, dass so Klempner und heizungsbauer offensichtlich jetzt so ein großes Berufsfeld hier so ist, was jetzt irgendwie so die Menge an Rohren, die so aussieht wie in einer großen Heiz- oder Kühlanlage ist.
Ja, 630 Kühlkreisläufe, die ins Vakuum reingehen und wieder raus. Also das ist eine Ansage. Also Kühlkreisläufe sind nicht einzelne Leitungen, sondern das sind eben halt mit Verteilern und so weiter und so weiter. Also das ist schon ein extrem komplexes System und wie gesagt, das gibt es sonst gar nicht auf der Welt. Andere Fusionsmaschinen, die auch in Richtung dauerstrich gehen, da gibt es in China eine große Aktivität. Das heißt, es ist der East-Hooker-Markt, der sich da auch vorarbeitet zum dauerbetrieb. Denn den LHD-Steller-Rat, der in Japan und auch der K-Star im Korea, das sind so die drei dauerstrich-anlagen, die haben alle drei eher so eine Art Tippeltappeltour. Das heißt, die gehen so Hölzchen für Klötzchen so vor. Und wir haben es eigentlich mit einem Schlag jetzt gemacht. Also mit einem ganz großen, großen, kühnen Schlag. Einfach so umgestellt auf Rums-Wasserkühlung.
Das war schon sehr unangenehm.
Ja, das war Mist.
Wie habt ihr denn das überhaupt eingebaut gekriegt? Denn einen Eindruck, an den ich mich noch sehr live erinnere, förmlich beim letzten, bei der letzten Besuchung, das war, da war kein Platz.
Wir haben alles Hecke rissen.
Schon gar nicht, schon außerhalb eh nicht, aber innerhalb halt auch nicht. Wie habt ihr denn da überhaupt die Wasserrohre noch reingekriegt?
Na, wir haben die Maschine nackig gemacht. Also wir haben quasi alles wieder rausgebaut. Nicht so viel wie nötig, und es war erstaunlich viel nötig.
Aber es war nicht irgendwie eigentlich schon vorgesehen, dass da noch was da reinkommt, sondern...
Da, da.
Oh, okay.
Also als ihr das erste Mal da wart, waren wir, ich weiß nicht immer das politisch-rechtlich sagt, aber wir waren in einer Art Testbetrieb. Also wir hatten die sogenannte Test-Diverter-Unit eingebaut. Das waren passiv gekühlte Diverter, das heißt, es war letztendlich nicht ein Blockgrafik, der dann warm geworden ist. Und der grundsätzliche Plan für W7X von Anfang an war, dass es eine wassergekühlte Maschine war.
Also wir haben jetzt den Zustand erreicht, den sie haben sollte. Also sozusagen, wir haben jetzt geliefert, was bestellt wurde, aus der Perspektive der Geldgeber. Aber auch in Abstimmung mit den Geldgebern, also ein bisschen aufs politische Element, haben wir gesagt, naja, also das heißt dieser vollausbau, also das heißt diese dauerbetriebsfähigkeit, lassen wir es doch mal eine Runde dazwischendrehen. Ohne dauerbetriebsfähigkeit, um überhaupt erstmal was zu machen, um das Team zusammenzubringen, um etwas zu lernen über das Plasma, um überhaupt zu zeigen, dass das grundsätzlich alles ganz ordentlich geht. Und auch um einfach mal Luft zu holen für diesen letzten großen Schlag.
Und habt ihr jetzt in der Testbetriebszeit Sachen gelernt, wo ihr gesagt habt, okay, wenn wir jetzt gleich von Anfang an die Wasserkühlung eingebaut hätten, hätten wir uns vertan?
Also wir hätten, also wenn man es ganz drastisch sagen will, hätten wir diesen wassergekühlten Divertor, also das ist der Bereich im Gefäß, der die höchste Wärmelast abfangen muss. Auch die Abfuhr, wo die Abfuhr von Wärme und von Teilchen organisiert wird mit starken Pumpen und was ganz stark instrumentiert ist und ganz stark ausgelegt ist, also sozusagen der Aschekasten. Also das heißt, da landet der ganze, da landet alles, was man loswerden will. Dafür haben wir auch den schönen Begriff exhaust, Auspuff. Auspuff hört sich schon blöd an. Denkt man so ein Moped oder sowas. Also der Bereich, der ist besonders kompliziert, besonders belastet, besonders sensibel und auch technisch besonders anspruchsvoll. Und wie Adrian schon sagte, da haben wir erstmal ein stark vereinfachtes Ding, also einen Testdivertor eingebaut, wo viel weggelassen ist, insbesondere die ganze Wasserkühlung, die ganze Verrohung weggelassen ist. Und beim einbau dieses Testdivertors haben wir technologisch enorm viel gelernt. Und die Bewertung im Nachhinein ist, vielleicht hätten wir den jetzigen gar nicht reingekriegt, schon gar nicht in der Zeit, wenn wir nicht einmal diese Runde gedreht hätten. Wenn wir da nicht schon die ganzen Werkzeuge, die Technologien, die Hebewerkzeuge, Positionierwerkzeuge schon mal alle gebaut hätten und dann die dann auch nochmal stark verfeinert haben.
Das sind ja unglaublich schwere Klötze, die müssen ja durch diese Menschschleusen dann einmal auch durchgereicht werden. Den kann man nicht einfach mal so mit einem Monteur drin irgendwie reinschmeißen, sondern das muss ja auch geregelt dann in die Maschine reingebracht werden und dann am Ende also Submillimeter genau dann auch montiert werden. Also dieser riesen schweren Trumme, die zum Teil...
Um Zahlen zu nehmen bis zu 70 Kilo und ausrichtungsgenauigkeit 0,1 Millimeter und händisch. Das heißt also mit zwei Personen und dann so. Ich meine natürlich händisch richtet man das hier auf 0,1 Millimeter aus, das geht ja gar nicht. Sondern dafür braucht man dann genau Werkzeuge, also solche Positionierwerkzeuge, auf die das dann raufgeladen wird und dann wird mit Kurbeln so Millimeter genau über ganz hohe Übersetzungen nicht dieser Submillimeterbereich dann erreicht und dann überhaupt mit Leeren wird das dann noch nachjustiert und werden kleine Scheiben dazwischen gelegt und hat man da justierschrauben, die man dann so von oben bedienen muss, alles sehr unbequem.
Und das heißt aber, habt ihr dann quasi so einen, mit diesem iterativen Ansatz, seid ihr so ein bisschen eigentlich auch so ein bisschen in dem Mainstream von, wie man heutzutage so Projekte macht, dass man halt einfach immer weiter iteriert und versucht möglichst schnell zu iterieren. Und hat alle Sachen daraus, also man sagt, okay, man kann es gar nicht alles im grünen Tisch planen, weil die Komplexität viel zu hoch ist und iteriert sich halt hinterher.
Das hört sich jetzt überlegter an, als das war. Vieles hat sich so schicksalhaft ergeben. Weil natürlich ganz am Anfang, das ist ja immer so dieser gefürchtete Projektoptimismus, so ganz am Anfang dachte man, naja, dann machen wir das alles so nicht in einem bestimmten zeitraum und machen das genauso.
Halt einmal ein Bier, ich mach das mal.
Und dann stellt man, wenn man dann anfängt, fest, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und im Endeffekt hat sich das durch diese gesamten 17 Jahre bauzeit, Projektzeit da gezogen, dass wir während des bauens gelernt haben, wie wir es machen. Und da sind in der Tat manchmal solche Schleifen, also dass man sagt, jetzt machen wir ein Ausweichmanöver und bauen erst mal etwas Simpleres und lernen dabei, wie man dieses simple baut, lernen wir dann, wie man das eigentliche baut. Das hat sich dann auch so organisch ergeben. Manchmal einfach aus Notsituation heraus mal festgestellt, das kriegen wir gar nicht hin. Also was machen wir denn? Da muss man eine Lösung finden. Da war dann manchmal vor allem die Lösung, okay, in radikales Vereinfachen bauen wir erst mal etwas auf, gucken mal, nicht gucken mal, was das bedeutet. Und anhand dessen können wir dann entwickeln, was es denn braucht, um denn die eigentliche Lösung in einem nächsten Schritt auf die Beine zu stellen.
Und habt ihr eigentlich ein komplettes digitales Modell der Anlage?
Ja, ein digital twin.
Und worin macht ihr das?
Katia.
Katia, ja?
Katia V5 ist es.
Das, okay, krass, das ist wahrscheinlich eines der größten Modelle, was man so...
Ja, Katia macht auch schon dicke Backen da, also das ist ein mächtiges System. Das ist eine gewaltige Software, die ist sehr beeindruckend.
Das ganze Maschine reinladen dauert auch mal so eine halbe Stunde, weil man es sich mit allen Komponenten reinladen lässt, aber ich bin auch immer ganz beeindruckt, dass wenn ich mit unseren Ingenieuren da so durchfahre, mit ihrer Space-Mouse, dann hab ich auch immer überhaupt keine Ahnung, wie wir so effizient durchnavigieren. Ich bin auch total durcheinander und weiß gar nicht, wo wir hingucken. Es ist halt auch eine voll dreidimensionale Maschine, das wollt ich auch noch sagen, zum divertereinbau, das ist ja... Also Vermessung ist ja auch nochmal ein ganzes Thema für sich, wie man Dinge überhaupt lokalisiert in der Maschine. Es gibt auch unterschiedliche Koordinatensysteme für die Komponenten im Gefäß und außerhalb, die auch zum Teil nicht ganz übereinstimmen. Das heißt, es gibt so eine kleine Abweichung, die man dann noch mit berücksichtigen muss. Und das Ganze dann in einem 3D-Modell, also im Cartier-Modell, abzubilden und dann da allein schon klarzukommen zwischen dem ganzen Rohrzeug und überhaupt was für zu designen. Da bin ich auch immer schwer beeindruckt, wie am Ende da allein schon den Platz finden, um irgendwie eine kompetente Unterzubringung zu machen.
Du hast uns gestern gesagt, dass der Unterschied zwischen gekühlt und warm 16 cm gefäßausdehnung sind.
Von den Spulen. Kranz.
Ja. Was ja, also wie macht man das denn? Weil ich meine, dann hast du ja quasi dein Koordinatensystem, wo du den Teil hast. Ist das dann temperaturabhängig oder?
Ja, das ist, gerade bei den Spulen ist das relativ abgefahren, weil die Spulen ja nicht nur bei Kälte schrumpfen, also um halt mehrere Zentimeter, sondern dann auch unter Last, also sowohl unter der Gewichtslast, als auch unter der Last des Magnetfeldes selber, also durch Schrumpf, der durch diese total krummen Spulen durchgeht, nochmal komplett anders wird. Das heißt, die Spulen, die begradigen sich tatsächlich im Betrieb so ein bisschen. Ja. Und gar nicht so wenig. Also ich dachte immer, sind das halt irgendwie ein paar, weiß nicht, Mikrometer oder so, das sind ja richtig dicke Teile. Nee, das sind mehrere Millimeter, die sich dann so gerade biegen. Und das hat am Ende reale Auswirkungen, auch für uns Physiker nämlich, dass das dann tatsächlich das Magnetfeld auch komplett anders aussieht. Das heißt, man muss dann zum Schluss auch wieder gegensteuern. Und wenn man, gerade wenn man eine bestimmte Krümmung des Magnetfelds erreichen möchte, muss man am Ende mit den, deswegen haben wir modulare Spulen, nehmen wir nochmal die planaren Spulen außenrum, müssen wir quasi diese Effekte dann letztendlich wieder ausgleichen. Das durch Messungen, nicht nur mechanische Messungen, sondern tatsächlich auch Magnetfeldmessungen im Gefäß, dann quasi wieder rückwärts hinbiegen, damit wir tatsächlich am Ende das Magnetfeld haben, was wir bestellt haben.
Woher wisst ihr denn, wie weit sich das ausdehnen kann? Also wenn jetzt irgendwie eine Notabschaltung oder irgendso eine, ob irgendwas passiert, was noch nie irgendwie in Betrieb war, kann es sein, dass sie sich dann nochmal 5 Zentimeter mehr irgendwie?
Nö, also bei raumtaportur ist Schluss. Also schlimmer kann es nicht werden. Und es ist ja sehr viel Masse. Es sind ja was kalte Masse, 400 Tonnen oder so?
Ja, 430 Tonnen.
430 Tonnen. Das passiert ja nicht mal so schnell. Wir sind jetzt gerade dabei, die Maschine aufzuwärmen nach der letzten Betriebsphase. Und das dauert halt ein paar Wochen. Einfach die Trägheit und die gute thermische Isolierung, die letztendlich dafür sorgt, dass die Schwulen nur langsam warm werden. Das heißt, es passiert nicht, dass mal schnell eine Spule einfach heiß wird. Und dann das Schlimmste, was passieren kann, ist, dass wir die Superleitung im Betrieb verlieren. Und was wir in dem Fall machen, ist, dass wir die gesamte magnetische Energie dann auf einen Schlag, also innerhalb von einer Sekunde, dann aus dem Magnetsystem rausleiten, weil uns die Spulen halt so heilig sind, weil wir die unglaublich schlecht auch mechanisch wieder rankommen würden. Und deswegen dann mehrere Sicherheitsmechanismen haben, die quasi eine Art Notabschaltung dafür sorgen.
Sieben Sekunden.
Sieben Sekunden?
Ja, das ist wichtig. Weil in einer Sekunde würden wir zu viel Spannung induzieren. Das wäre furchtbar.
Es war früher mal eine Sekunde, oder nicht?
Nee, das waren mal drei. Okay, sorry. Aber das haben wir dann verlängert, um im Fall eines Quench weniger induzierte Spannung zu haben. Wichtige Änderung dabei. Jetzt beginnen wir mit den Kleinigkeiten reinzukommen. Aber man muss sich unterscheiden. Dieses ganze Magnetsystem ist ein elastisches System. Das ist nicht fest. Das hat Elastizität. Muss es auch haben. Wenn es nicht elastisch wäre, würde man zu hohe mechanische Spannung bekommen. Dann würde man die Materialien überlasten. Das heißt, da muss man so einen Kompromiss machen zwischen Elastizität, Beweglichkeit, die mechanische Spannung rausnimmt und Steifigkeit, die erwünscht ist, damit sie sich nicht zu sehr bewegt. Aber dann muss man sich mit hohen mechanischen Spannungen auseinandersetzen. Das heißt, da ist auch so ein Kompromiss, da muss man sich durch juckeln durch das Ganze. Und dann muss man bei der Elastizität, also das ist elastisch. Und dann die Bewegung, da gibt es einerseits die thermische Bewegung. Also das heißt einfach das Schrumpfen beim Abkühlen und das Expandieren wieder beim Aufwärmen. Wie Adrian sagte, ist das ein furchtbar langsamer Prozess. Das Krüe ist immer langsam, weil das ist Helium, das hat nicht viel Wärmekapazität. Und dieses Helium, um diese 400 Tonnen runter zu kühlen oder wieder aufzuwärmen, das dauert halt ewig. Krüe ist immer langsam. Also das ist ein Prozess, der auf Wochen passiert. Und die andere Beweglichkeit, die entsteht durch magnetische Kräfte, einfach was Magnete miteinander machen. Und das ist einerseits die Kräfte, die die Magnete auf sich selbst ausüben, also aufgrund des Stroms, der durchführt. Und da ist mal die faustformel, das Magnete wollen flach und rund werden, aber sie sind bei uns eben weder flach noch rund. Also sie sind nicht planar, also das heißt nicht in der Ebene und auch nicht rund. Alle Kräfte da drin richten sich so aus, in Richtung flach und rund. Da muss man die Magnete natürlich hindern, dass sie flach und rund werden. Das geschieht durch Stahlgehäuse, die die eingebettet sind. Die nehmen diese Kräfte auf und die Stahlgehäuse geben diese Kräfte dann wieder an das gesamte mechanische System weiter, sodass insgesamt ein mechanostatisches Gesamtgefüge wie so ein Gerüst, wie so ein Fachwerk in einem haus entsteht, wo die Kräfte dann rundum verteilt werden. Alles das ist auch gerechnet mit viel definite Elemente-Methoden. Da haben wir auch eines der größten Modelle der Welt, glaube ich mit über eine Million Knoten oder so was. Das ist das globale Modell unseres Magnetsystems, wo wir also die gesamten Bewegungen berechnen können. Da passieren also keine Überraschungen, sondern das ist alles komplett numerisch vorhersagbar in vernünftigen Neuigkeitsganzen.
Eine Frage, die wir noch hatten von der letzten Sendung, war, warum sind denn diese Magneten so verbogen und warum ist dieser ganze Stillerator so eine komische, oder man doch denkt, so ein Donut von so einem Thorus, das wäre doch irgendwie...
Sieht viel eleganter aus.
Die Dreidimensionalität ist tatsächlich das, was auch einen Stillerator ausmacht. Das hat sich ergeben aus einem sehr langwierigen Optimierungsprozess. Das heißt, unser Stillerator ist optimiert, um bestimmte Transportprozesse klein zu halten. Das heißt, um das Plasma-Confignment besser zu machen. Diese Optimierung macht man letztendlich auf der Form des Magnetfeldes. Und das Problem, wie das dann läuft, ist, man setzt da halt ein Team von Theoretikern ran, die einem letztendlich sagen, um bestimmte Instabilitäten zu unterdrücken, um bestimmte Transportkanäle zu unterbinden, muss das Magnetfeld lokal bestimmte Krümmungseigenschaften haben, muss es bestimmte Maxima und Minima haben. Und wenn man diese ganzen Optimierungsritieren miteinander verbindet, dann kommt eine Form des Magnetfeld-Käfigs, also letztendlich der wirklich magnetischen Flussflächen, heraus. Sieht halt so aus, das ist dann oft gar nicht baubar. Also einfach weil es keine Spulen gibt, die dieses Magnetfeld erzeugen könnten. Dann nimmt man quasi von dort dann oft wieder Schritte zurück und sagt, gut, dann führen wir noch als Randbedingung, dass es baubare Spulen geben muss, die ein Mindestkrümungsradius haben. Weil der Krümungsradius gibt einem dann natürlich auch die mechanischen Eigenschaften vor. genau, und dann endet man am Ende bei einem Kompromissfeld, was hoffentlich noch nahe genug ist an dem optimalen Feld mit den gegebenen Optimierungskriterien, um die gewünschten Transporteigenschaften zu erzeugen. Und dann geht man damit zu den Ingenieuren und sagt, ist das machbar? Und leider kommen dann halt gerade diese Spulen raus. Das heißt, das ist letztendlich, dass das, ja, das Design der Spulen ist nachrangig dem, was wir letztendlich für Eigenschaften vom Magnetfeld hätten. Und wir sind da immer am Rande von dem, was halt gerade noch einfach technisch machbar ist.
Und positiv formulieren will, dann sind...
Ich fand das jetzt gar nicht so negativ.
Nein, das war auch nicht negativ. Aber noch positiver formulieren will. Dann ist das die natürlichste Form der Spulen. Also das heißt, man hat die Physik befragt, man befragt letztendlich das Plasma, was hättest du denn gerne? Und da sagt das Plasma, das Magnetfeld. Und dann guckt man, welche Spulen erzeugen dieses Magnetfeld. So wie Adrian sagt, muss man manchmal sagen, nee, geht nicht so zu teuer, das wird technisch nicht umsetzbar. Und dann verhandelt man da ein bisschen rum. Dann macht man eben halt ein fast optimales Magnetfeld für das Plasma. Aber die Frage stellt man an das Plasma. Und das war eine fundamentale Änderung des Vorgehens, wenn man es vergleicht so mit den noch bis in die 80er-Jahre rein. Wo man sich ad hoc Magnetfelder überlegt hat. Man hat gesagt, nehmen wir mal Sonnenspule, nehmen wir mal Sonnenspule, Doppelhelix, was auch immer, was gerade so rum lag, was einem gerade eingefallen ist. Und hat dann dieses Magnetfeld erzeugt und das Plasma eingefüllt und dann so geguckt, was passiert. Allzu oft war es so, dass das Plasma damit nicht happy war. Also das heißt, ganz Instabilitäten ausgebildet, dann ist das wie wild rausdiffundiert. Dann hat das, dann haben die schnellen Teilchen ganz schnell ihren Weg rausgefunden, alles Mögliche, was man nicht haben wollte. Was denn letztlich daran lag, dass man einfach irgendein Feld genommen hat im Ad hoc. Und da hat man mal den Spieß umgedreht, hat gesagt, kann ich aus den Grundgleichungen der Plasmaphysik ableiten, welches Magnetfeld es braucht? So und dann hat man das Feld gefunden, das heißt die Feldverteilung, lokale Krümmungen, Variationen des Magnetfeldes. Und dann berät man die Maxwell-Gleichung einfach um und berechnet dann, welche Stromfäden, also welcher stromverlauf erzeugt dieses Magnetfeld. Und dann ergeben sich diese Stromfäden, die gruppiert man zu Spulen und dann kriegt man die Spulen, wie sie halt so sind. In dem Sinn ist es wirklich so eine Art genetischer Zugang sozusagen, oder so ein evolutionärer Zugang. Das heißt also, das ergibt sich so, wie es denn tatsächlich für das Plasma optimal ist. Ein bisschen kann man sagen, das ist halt wie die Form eines Blattes, würde man auch nicht hinterfragen. Warum sieht ein Blatt so komisch aus? Warum hat es Zacken?
genau, das finde ich also diesen interessanten Teil, dass es irgendwie so der intuitive Zugang zum Universum ist, ja immer so ein bisschen Symmetrie geneigt, also so ein Spiegel symmetrisch, das aber ganz viel des Universums eben nicht so ist. Sondern irgendwie...
Also der Stellarator und unser ist tatsächlich räumlich nicht besonders symmetrisch. In bestimmten Koordinaten gibt es allerdings schon Symmetrien. Da kann man lange anfangen, Stellaratoren und allgemein Fusionsmaschinen zu klassifizieren. Ich glaube, das wollen wir hier nicht unbedingt machen. Aber unser gehört zu einer ganz bestimmten Klasse von Stellaratoren, weil er annähernd, jetzt kommt ein großes Wort, quasi isodynamisch ist. Und letztendlich sich daraus auch bestimmte Eigenschaften ergeben, die seine Stabilität dann auch betreffen.
Die Mathematiker nennen das so versteckte Symmetrien. Also da kommt es drauf an, welche nichtnatürlichen Koordinaten, also welche nichtkathesischen Koordinaten man nimmt. Und dann entdeckt man diese Symmetrien. Das sind darin versteckte Symmetrien. Aber da wird es lustig und sehr wunderschön mathematisch, also sehr ästhetisch, die ganze Angelegenheit. Aber letztlich erstmal, wenn man drauf guckt, dann erschließt sich das so nicht unbedingt. Aber stimmt schon, die Natur ist nicht zwingenderweise rechtwinklig oder rund. Also wenn man auch das Skelett eines Säugetiers nimmt, das ist einfach auch an das Leben optimiert, nicht so wie es eh mal sein soll. Da gibt es auch nur so ein paar wenige Symmetrien drin, so ein Spiegelsymmetrie links-rechts, nicht so. Brustkasten links-rechts sieht ziemlich ähnlich aus, oder so was, man hat gerade so eine Flipsymmetrie da drin. Und ansonsten, wenn man der Achse nachgeht, ne, also damit ist es eigentlich, deshalb sag ich mal gerne, unsere Magneten sind völlig natürlich. Das hat die Natur uns so gesagt.
Quasi Biomagneten.
Das ist ein Biomagnet, ja. Das sag ich ein schönes Wort dafür.
Was ich noch interessant finde, tatsächlich an unserer bestimmten Konfiguration, ist, die ist ja jetzt schon alt. Also wir sind ja lange im bau. Und auch das Design von Vizimix war von den Optimierungskriterien ja dann natürlich noch älter und ist auch durch einen langwierigen Prozess durchlaufen. Was will man denn wirklich zum Schluss? Aber angefangen hat man, vor allem wenn ich mich ja falsch liege, aber so in den 80ern schon. Das heißt, da liegen ja schon ein paar Jahre zwischen. Und was ich abgefahren finde, ist, dass, obwohl Stellarator-Optimierung immer noch ein sehr aktives Feld ist, man auch mit immer neuen Designs um die Ecke kommt, was man jetzt vielleicht neu ausprobieren möchte oder anders bauen würde, ist VisiMix trotzdem immer noch sehr gut dabei. Also die Optimierungskriterien, die waren gut gewählt. Und es ist immer noch eine sehr moderne Maschine in dem Sinne, dass es immer noch nah an Designs rankommt, die man heute, wenn man von neu anfangen würde, halt, ja, also da gibt es erstaunliche Ähnlichkeiten und wir müssen uns da nicht verstecken, dass wir jetzt irgendwie inzwischen 30 Jahre altes Design hier rumfahren, sondern das ist immer noch gut.
Also trotz aller, sagen wir, aller starkeren Verfügbarkeit von höheren Rechenleistungen und so, waren die Optimierungen, die seitdem passiert sind, eher nur so graduell demgegenüber.
Die gehen oft in eine unterschiedliche Richtung, also man optimiert nicht nur für einen Kriterium. Und inzwischen gibt es neue Stellaradordesigns, die man, glaub ich, auch gerne mal bauen würde. Aber es ist nicht so, dass sich herausgestellt hat, dass unsere jetzt irgendwie katastrophal schlecht ist oder dass man im Nachhinein denkt, hm, mistens, hätte man es doch irgendwie ganz anders gebaut mit dem Wissen, was man seitdem hat. Ja, ne, aber das finde ich dann schon, der erste, der zugekommen ist, als das Projekt dann schon im bau war, kann man sich ja schon die Frage stellen, ist das denn überhaupt das Richtige? Aber es ist nicht falsch.
Und wenn man jetzt, also apropos, wenn man jetzt sozusagen die nächste Generation bauen würde, sind wir denn schon so weit, dass man, sagen wir mal, Hochtemperatur-Superleiter für die Spulen nehmen könnte, uns halt ohne Helium hinbekäme? Oder sind wir da noch, noch eine Ecke weg von?
Das ist gerade großes Thema. Also das ist sozusagen jetzt die, die technologische Entwicklung, die am meisten ändern könnte, nicht die so Game-Changer würde ich gerne nennen. Also die Hochtemperatur-Superleitung, die hat jetzt ja gerade den Schritt geschafft, vom reinen Leiter, vom gradlinigen Leiter, wo man eben halt Strom durchschickt, zu vernünftigen Spulen, dass man überhaupt Spulen draus bauen kann. Also etwa die Superleitenden Spulen, die so im krankenhausbetrieb hier für MR-Geräte und so was, da für MRT-Geräte verwendet werden, das sind alles immer noch konventionelle Superleiter. Weil das eine gut funktionierende, wohl etablierte Technik ist. Das heißt, da ist man jetzt so gerade an dem technologischen Übergang, dass man sich so traut, daraus was zu bauen. Dann gleich den Schritt zu machen zu nichtplanaren Spulen, der ist auch technologisch nicht ganz ohne.
Der Fertigungs?
Ja, auch vom Betriebsprinzip her, also Hochtemperatur-Superleiter mögen das gar nicht so gerne, unter mechanischen Spannungen zu stehen. Das liegt daran, dass diese atomaren Lagen, in diesen seltenen Erde-basierten Keramiken, da passieren, dass die atomaren Lagen, die Lage zueinander anscheinend sehr wichtig ist. Man hat das auch von der Physik her gar nicht verstanden. Es gibt gar keine Theorie für die Hochtemperatur-Superleitung.
Das ist ziemlich zwinglich, das merkt man in Teilforschung, oder?
Ja, das ist auch ein bisschen peinlich, dass man das gar nicht versteht. Das ist eigentlich ganz schrecklich. Aber es gibt so viel Evidenz darauf, dass die relative Lage der Atomlagen zueinander sehr, sehr wichtig ist und dass dann eben sehr schnell auch die Superleitung sich wieder verkrümelt, also ein Quench passiert. Und deshalb muss man damit sehr, sehr vorsichtig umgehen. Und solche Scherspannung, das heißt, die machen ja genau gerade solche Verschiebungen zueinander. Das ist also nicht, nicht ganz ohne überhaupt Spulen daraus zu bauen. Deshalb wird das ja eher aus solchen graden Segmenten sozusagen in so einem Polygonenzugang werden die so zusammengestrickt und dann durch entsprechendes Miteinanderverbinden werden daraus Spulen gepatcht. Da gibt es eben halt jetzt für die ersten Prototypen Spulen, die Entwicklungsrichtung geht zurzeit so bei denjenigen, die da den Weg verfolgen, viel mehr in Richtung, wo es fällt als andere Kühlung. Denn die Sprungtemperatur, also das Maximalfeld, was man damit erzeugen kann, also das Sprungfeld, das kritische Feld, das ist bei Hochtemperatur-Supra-Leitern viel viel höher angesiedelt, sodass man also viel stärkere Felder erzeugen kann damit.
Das heißt also man würde immer noch Helium nehmen, aber dann...
Dann würde man immer noch mit Helium kühlen, würde aber viel höhere Felder erzeugen können, was denn die ganzen Anlagen kleiner machen. Und besser ist für einen Einschluss, stärkeres Feld, besserer Einschluss, kann man so über den daumen sagen.
Oder andersrum, wenn man eine gleichgroße Maschine hat mit einem größeren Feld, dann kommt man auch zu höheren Temperaturen, oder?
Also auch das eben mal überwässern, wenn man Probleme hat mit dem Einschluss. Aber bei gleichem Einschluss können wir die Maschinen kleiner machen und so was. Das ist auch attraktiv.
Das ist interessant, weil wir letztes Mal eigentlich das Gegenteil gesagt hatten, dass es attraktiver ist, eine größere Maschine zu bauen, weil irgendwie Fläche-Volumen-Verhältnis besser ist.
Also mit kleinen Maschinen hat man auch Probleme. Weil das dann etwa die Wärmeflüsse auf die am stärksten belasteten Bereiche natürlich immer weiter konzentriert. Man macht das alles immer in kleiner, ist der gleiche Wärmefluss. Das wird dann alles immer intensiver, die Angelegenheit. Also das heißt, mit dem Brümmen Nixorost, also mit der Abfuhr, mit dem Aschenbecher bekommt man massiv Probleme, da wo man Maschinen so klein und kompakt macht, mit Hilfe eines hohen Feldes. Das wissen unsere Kollegen, die da in die Richtung gehen, auch sehr genau und da gibt es sehr intensive Forschungsaktivitäten. Der andere Vorteil von Hochtemperatur-Superleitern, dass man eventuell das Helium als Kühlung loswerden würde, finde ich persönlich auch technologisch sehr attraktiv.
Das Stickstoff ist aber viel einfacher.
Ja, Stickstoff ist aus mehreren Gründen einfacher. Das ist erstmal billiger. Das hilft auch schon mal. Helium muss ja mühsam aus dem bauch der Erde rausgepult werden. Stickstoff ist einfach in unserer Atmosphäre schon reichlich enthalten. Das ist aber so ein anderer Kostenfaktor, der dran ist. Auch die Ingenieurtechnik ist viel einfacher. Das ist ein größeres Molekül. Und deshalb sucht sich Helium nicht so diese Mikrolex, die sind tückisch. Also das heißt, die allerkleinsten Lex, so eine nicht ganz perfekte Schweißnaht, ist ja immer gleich ein Leck bei Helium. Helium, gerade bei tiefen Temperaturen, hat eine so geringe Viskosität. Das ist eben von der Viskosität gleich Null, Superfluidität. So eine Viskosität, das sucht sich den kleinsten Miniriss als Leck von raus. Und da hat man gleich ein Heliumleck. Wenn man ein Heliumleck hat, dann kann man nach hause gehen. Das ist ganz katastrophal, das ist enorm schwer zu finden. Und die Technologie würde sich also enorm vereinfachen, wo man flüssigen Stickstoff kühlen könnte. Aber das schließt einander nicht aus. Zurzeit wird viel stärker in Richtung starkes Feld gepusht.
Weil wir noch genug Helium haben, so grob.
Weil es auch noch ein bisschen Forschung ist und weil das Kompakt- und Kleinsein auch attraktiv ist.
Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt morgen anfangen würde, würde man noch nicht mit Hochtemperatur-Superleitern bauen. Allein schon, weil das Risiko so groß ist. Ich hatte gestern, als wir rumgegangen sind, auch noch mal deutlich gemacht, wir kommen ja unglaublich schlecht an unsere Spulen wieder ran. Wenn irgendwas mit denen sein sollte, ist das ein unglaublicher Aufwand, wieder an diese Spulen ranzukommen und eine Spule komplett auszubauen, ist pur.
Das erste, was man jetzt machen muss, ist ein Prototyp nicht planarer Hochtemperatur-Superleit, eine Spule bauen, die auf einem Bank liegt, die auf einem Tisch liegt, die man runterkühlt. Ob jetzt mit dem Ziel, starkes Feld zu erzeugen oder mit dem Ziel, mit flüssig Stickstoff zu kühlen, egal. Man kann beide Ziele mal verfolgen dabei, die auf Herz und Nien zu überprüfen, zu demonstrieren, das geht.
Also, dass die auch einfach mehrere Zyklen durchhält.
Ja, dass die lange durchhält und so, dass das robust ist, dass sie auch einen Quench überlebt. Unsere Spulen haben wir alle einen Quench ausgesetzt. Wir haben alle einen Quenchtest gemacht. Das heißt, wo wir die Spulen mit Strom belegt haben, mit 15.000, 16:000 Ampere Strom belegt haben, haben dann die Temperatur langsam von 4 Kelvin immer weiter hochgefahren, so bis knapp 8 oder so was. Und dann machen die Quenchtest, dann ist die Superleitung weg. Und dann greift der ganze Mechanismus ein, den Strom schnell rauszunehmen. Die Spule kommt ordentlich unter Kraft, weil in ganz kurzer Zeit wird der Strom rausgenommen. Das erzeugt starke magnetische Kräfte, Wirbelströme rundherum. Das muss man auch mindestens einmal gemacht haben. Ja, so zehnmal, nicht so, damit man sicher ist, das Ding überlebt das auch.
Und da ist man jetzt gerade mit planaren Spulen. Also CFS, Commonwealth, Fusion, die Ausgründung des MIT, die jetzt vorhaben, ein Hochfeld-Supra-Leiter, also Hochwelt-Hotemperatur-Superleiter-Turkarmak zu bauen. Die sind im Grunde im Moment eine Superleiterfirma. Das heißt, sie haben jetzt gerade oder vor inzwischen über einem Jahr ihre erste komplette Spule gebaut, haben die getestet, haben auch gezeigt, dass sie gut funktioniert und haben sie auch unabsichtlich schon einmal gequencht. Das heißt, da ist man jetzt an dem Punkt, wo man... Ein bisschen war das natürlich abzusehen oder ein Gesiko, was man halt so hinnimmt. Und das ist jetzt gerade halt so der Stand der Forschung. Man hat jetzt eine Spule gebaut. Und das müssen sie jetzt noch zuverlässiger und im Maßstab hinbekommen, dass sie daraus eine komplette Maschine bauen kann. Ja, aber das ist jetzt gerade so der Rand der Technologie, die möglich ist.
Ja, und es ist super wichtig, diese Entwicklung. Also die ist extrem, extrem bedeutend, weil diese gesamte Technologie und die Magnete sind eben auch das Schlüsselelement eines magnetischen Einschlussfusionsanlage, die diese Technologie ganz entscheidend vereinfachen und voranbringen kann. Denn im Prinzip, wenn man das mal in den Griff bekommen würde, kann man tatsächlich auch ein bisschen die Zukunft träumen und diese Hochtemperatur-Superleitenspulen drucken. Also tatsächlich mit additive manufacturing eben halt so machen, durch Schichten auftragen und in mehrere Lagen einfach so auftragen und so was. Das öffnet völlig neue Perspektiven, die alle noch zu erproben sind. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Weg, den man da gehen muss.
Ich habe noch die Frage, wenn die Hochtemperatur-Superleiter Keramik sind, ob die dann überhaupt verformbar sind oder ob die dann brechen. Wenn nein, also jetzt vorhin meint ihr, dass wenn die starken Magnetfelder anliegen, eure Spuren versuchen planarer zu werden, das ist ja ein Druck, den das dann aushalten müsste einfach. Geht das mit Keramik überhaupt oder bricht die dann?
Also das gibt einfach so einen maximalen Krummungsradius, den man so erlauben kann. Das kann man sich so vorstellen, wenn man so einen Teller nimmt, der ja auch aus Keramik ist, da kann man auch ein bisschen Kraft draus ausüben. Und wenn man da gut misst, so ein Millimeter oder so was oder zwei geht da schon. Ja, also auch Keramik hat eine gewisse Elastizität. Aber man hat eben auch eine relativ bald kommt dann auch schon die Bruchgrenze. Das ist kein sehr duktiles Material, anders als Metall. Metall ist einfach per se erstmal viel, viel duktiler, sodass man also nicht so schnell in die, von der Elastizität in den innen elastischen, in den Bruchbereich kommt. Und der Bruchbereich ist bei Keramiken immer sehr schnell vor der Tür, wenn man den elastischen Bereich verlässt. Also das muss man als Materialeigenschaft einfach mitrechnen. Das heißt, man kann dem weniger zumuten. Bei Metall muss man sich da nicht so viel, nicht so viel Sorge machen. Wenn unsere Magnete unter diesen Kräften sind und sich verformen, also um den Leiter mache ich mir da überhaupt keine Gedanken. Das ist Niob-Titan, das ist ein ganz konservativer Superleiter. Kann auch Niob-Zinn nehmen, da muss man ein bisschen mehr Gehampel machen. Nicht so, dass es so beidernimmt, die nimmt Niob-Zinn, weil man damit einfach stärkere Felder erzeugen kann. Aber Niob-Titan ist so der Wald und Wiesen-Superleiter, den jeder Superleitung machen kann.
Was wir letztes Mal nicht erklärt hatten, wo ich mir dachte, das müssen wir dieses Mal eigentlich fragen, so Sendung mit der maus mäßig, wieso braucht man eigentlich überhaupt Superleiter? Kann man nicht einfach viel billiger ohne Superleiter auch solche Magnetfelder kriegen oder geht das einfach gar nicht?
Also es gibt da zwei Aspekte. Auf der einen Seite würde man halt irrsinnig viel Leistung verbrauchen. Das ist so der einfachere Aspekt. Also man verliert halt einfach durch Resistivitäten, dann über Wärme sehr, sehr viel Leistung. Aber ganz grundsätzlich an die Felder, an die wir rankommen wollen, kommt man dann nicht mehr ran, allein schon aus Leistungsbilanz gönnen. Also es würde einfach zu heiß werden. Also 15 Kilohampere durch einen Normalleiter zu schicken und in so einem engen Spulgehäuse einzuklemmen, da kann man sich zu Tode kühlen. So viel Kühlmittel kriegt man da einfach nicht durchgedrückt.
Wie hoch ist denn der Abstand? Ist das irgendwie eine Größenordnung oder ist das zwei Größenordnungen oder ist das zehn Prozent oder so? Also ich kann einfach mal das Gefühl dafür kriegen.
Sofaleiter verbraucht ja gar keine Leistung.
Nee klar, aber so wie viel mehr Kühlung, weiß ich nicht. Also nicht mehr, die Frage ist halt, geht das einfach so wenig, so offensichtlich gar nicht, dass man überhaupt nicht gucken muss? Oder könnte es sein, dass morgen jemand kommt und sagt, das geht aber doch?
Also es gibt zum Teil oder es gab einen sehr schönen Druckermark. Viele Druckermarks sind erstmal normal leitend auch. Ja, wenn man es so gepulst und kurz macht, dann kann man auch damit leben, dass halt kurzzeitig sehr viel Leistung in die Spulen deponiert wird. Das ist dann einfach quasi durch die, man hat einfach große schwere Spulen und die werden dann halt heiß. Das ist dann halt, nimmt man in kauf. Das heißt dauerstrechbetrieb ist dann ausgeschlossen. Der schöne Alcatraz C-Mod, das war der Druckermark vom MIT bis vor jetzt inzwischen fünf, sechs Jahren. Die haben mit flüssigen Stickstoff gekühlt und die haben einfach riesige Mengen flüssigen Stickstoff durch die Maschine durchgedrückt und dann tatsächlich irrsinnig hohe Felder auch hinbekommen. Das war eine Zeit lang der feldstärkste Druckermark, der betrieben wurde und war auch echt beeindruckend, was sie mit so einer kleinen Maschine auch alles geschafft haben. Ja, aber das war schon brutal, also mit Hochdruck, also über den Tag so ein paar Tonnen flüssigem Stickstoff, der komischerweise auch gar nicht in einen geschlossenen kreislauf lief, sondern das wurde halt morgens in einem LKW geliefert. Dann kommt Tank direkt durch die Maschine, einfach quasi auf die Straße gekippt. Das kann man machen.
Günstiger als eine Reiferflüssigungsanlage oder?
Bei jedem Kammer draus das Nö. Das Stickstoff ist ja billig, das lassen sie sich einfach anliefern. Ist auch vielleicht so ein amerikanischer Zugang.
War auch gepulst.
War auch gepulst, ja genau.
Gut, aber der Grund, warum ich frage wäre natürlich, dass man ja im Moment eine Menge Energie und Aufwand in die Kühlung investiert. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt nicht superleiter kühlen müsste, hätte ich aber mehr Aufwand, weil ich immer noch die Spulen kühlen muss.
Ja, wenn wir das mal so in Zahlen reingießen. Also unser Kühlschrank hier für den Wendel-Chancy-Mix, der hat so einen Stromanschluss von 2 Megawatt etwa.
Das ist bei ihm Kohlekraftwerk, ne?
Ja, 2 Megawatt, ein kleines Kohlekraftwerk, so ein Stadt-Ding, nicht so irgendwie. Große Kohlekraftwerke haben von der Megawatt oder sowas einen Gigawatt, ne? Also 2 Megawatt, das ist schon ganz beträchtlich. Das läuft ja so 24-7 durch, das frisst auch auch nicht Strom, ja.
Unangenehm auf der Stromrechnung, einer unserer hauptbetriebskosten.
Das ist ein ordentlicher Posten auf der Stromrechnung, ja. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Vergleich den Tokamak in unserem Institut Astex Upgrade in Garching nehmen, dann zum Betrieb der Magnete wird aus dem Schwungradgenerator, ich glaube 400 Megawatt entnommen. Das heißt also am Ende haben wir ein Faktor 100 dazwischen. Das heißt also, wenn man rein hypothetisch diesen Kupfermagneten von diesem Tokamak, der obendrein noch Faktor 3 kleiner ist, die Anlage, wenn man den rein hypothetisch damit den Kupfermagneten betreiben würden, brauchten wir gut Faktor 100 mehr Leistung.
Okay, also dann lieber Superlater.
Dann lieber Superlater. Wenn man das dann eben auf ein Kraftwerk übersetzen würde, würde das Kraftwerk eben den Strom erzeugen, also den Strom erzeugen, den es braucht für sein Magnetfeld und damit ist es sinnlos.
Die Kühlung, die wir haben, die ist ja auch nicht als Ausgleich für die Leistung, die wir reinbringen im Betrieb, sondern ja tatsächlich der Verlust der Kühlung gegenüber der Außenwelt. Das heißt, auch wenn unsere thermische Abschlemmung unglaublich gut ist, das, wogegen unsere Kühlung arbeitet, ist einfach die Wärme, die von außen tatsächlich in Richtung der Spuren eindringt. Und die Kühlanlage hat nicht sehr viel mehr zu tun im Betrieb, als sie das zwischen Betriebsdagen einfach tut, um die Maschine kalt zu halten.
Also das ist ja der Witz bei der Superleitung, wenn man eine Superleitung hat, ist das verlustfrei. Verlustfrei bedeutet, es wird nichts vom Strom in Wärme umgesetzt. Nicht so ein idealer Bild. Und damit ist das wie ein Permanentmagnet. Also wenn man so ein Stabmagnet in der Hand hat, hat er auch einfach Magnetfeld. Und er macht immer Magnetfeld. Idealerweise ist das dann so. Und in der technischen, nicht ganz idealen Welt hat ein solcher superleitender Magnet natürlich auch Anschlüsse. Das heißt, da muss der Strom auch reingeführt werden. Und da gibt es gute technische Gründe, warum man dann am Ende das nicht komplett superleitend durchhält, sondern hat da auch normal leitende Elemente drin, die dann wiederum auch als Wärmeverlust dort reingehen, wo die Kühlanlage sich ein bisschen dagegen stinken muss. Das heißt, da ist auch noch mal so ein Megawatt oder so was, so Wärmeverluste insgesamt so drin. Aber insgesamt ist das die einzige vernünftige Art, starke Magnetfelder zu erzeugen.
Und die Kühlung, sozusagen die andere Kühlung, die wir vorhin geredet haben, die quasi eure Betriebswärmekühlung ist, die macht ihr einfach wirklich mit Wasser und Kühlturm oder?
Ja. Wasser ist ein super Kühlmittel.
Wir haben zwei große Becken, eins ist halt voll, das andere ist leer morgens und dann über den Tag, das bestimmt letztendlich auch unsere Pulslänge, also diese halbe Stunde, die wir uns als Ziel mehr oder weniger als Limit für die Maschine überlegt haben, bestimmt dann letztendlich auch wie groß die Kühlwassermenge sein muss und dementsprechend dann auch die Kühlbeckengröße. Dann pumpen wir quasi von einem ins andere rüber und über Nacht wird dann über ein relativ schnödes Kühlsystem dann einfach das Wasser wieder runtergekühlt und für den nächsten Tag vorbereitet.
Habt ihr euch noch einen Zumengpool daneben gestellt?
Das ist leider deionisiertes Wasser.
Ich meine, aber hätte noch einen wärmetausch oder rein schon können.
Ah, ja.
Und dann einfach...
Ein Fakusi auf dem Dach.
genau. Also ich meine, dann heißt das doch dann Kraft-Wärme-Kopplung oder so.
Ja.
Ist das...
Leider nicht.
Verbesserungsvorschlag. Gibt's eine Prämie für...
Ist aber blöderweise ein Strahlenschutz-Vereich das Dach.
Deswegen. Wasser dämmt... Der dämmt doch ganz gut, ist doch...
Ja...
Du hast ein Notiv gelöst in der Pool.
Okay, also ich hab trotzdem so ein bisschen das Ziel, hier den Elon Musk zu geben, der kommt und sagt, ihr müsst jetzt 50 Prozent einsparen, einfach mal, um Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, wird hier irgendwas verplempert oder nicht. Weil das klingt alles nach riesigen Ausgaben für Kühlung und für Supermagneten. Und das ist aber kein Frivol irgendwie, das ist cool, damit wollen wir spielen, sondern das ist alles nötig. Das würde ich gerne noch ein bisschen mehr beleuchten. Also jetzt gibt es irgendeine Luft, die man da irgendwie raus optimieren könnte noch jetzt, wo man weiß, irgendwie. Gab es irgendeine große Verschwendung vielleicht? Eigentlich nicht, oder?
Eigentlich nicht. Also wenn man sich das Magnetsystem so als solches anguckt, man würde es jetzt genauso auslegen, man würde es genauso designen, das ist ziemlich konservative Standardtechnik. Also das hört sich so völlig uninnovativ an. Aber das Konservativste, was wir eigentlich in unserer ganzen Maschine haben, ist das eigentliche superleitende System, ist alles ganz vorsichtig ausgelegt.
Weil man weiß, dass es funktioniert und hat es schon ein paar Mal gebaut, so ähnlich.
Und weil es ja auch unglaublich lange aushalten muss.
Ja, das ist wirklich Standardindustrie-Technik und man ist so konservativ, weil man sich tatsächlich Defekte nicht leisten kann, möchte zumindest. Deshalb geht man da einfach nicht so an die Kante des Machbaren. Und das ist auch genau der Punkt, weshalb man bei Superleitungen also mindestens einen Prototypen bauen muss, damit man dort etwas konservativer wird. Weil es nicht zu wagemutig wird, damit man es mal demonstriert hat. Also das ist das absolute Minimum. Wir sind jetzt von vorne auf der sicheren Seite, nicht mit unserer ganzen Technologie, weil das ist etwa seit 100 Jahren gibt es schon diesen Superleiter und sowas. Das heißt, das hat man alles gut verstanden und solche Magnete baut man auch schon seit Jahrzehnten. Dass sie jetzt nicht planar sind, ist eher so eine technische Finesse dabei. Aber generell ist das alles sehr konservativ, sehr Industriestandard technologisch ausgelegt. Insofern würde man es jetzt erst mal nicht anders bauen. Bei Hochtemperatur-Superleitern würde man vieles anders machen. Das wäre ganz gewiss so, allemal, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir können gut mit diesen etwas moderateren Feldern leben und gehen dann auch bei der Kühlungsseite auf höhere Temperaturen, würde das die gesamte Technologie und die Kosten dafür ganz drastisch runterbringen.
Aber so weit sind wir jetzt halt noch nicht, weil die Iterationen halt noch nicht durch sind. Das wären, wenn noch so Durchbrüche, wo ihr sagt, das wäre richtig gut, wenn wir da immer noch so einen technologischen Durchbruch hätten?
Na, AM, additive manufacturing, das ist auch heftiges Thema. Also, dass man letztlich, ja, ab die dargesagten Stellratur druckt.
Also, dass man halt Strukturen, also wie halt bei Raketentriebwerken, halt Strukturen, die man nicht wirklich fräsen kann.
Das ist ja bei uns unglaublich furchtbar. Zum Beispiel, also allein, wenn man sich das Plasmagefäß anguckt, aus was für Teilen, die völlig im Wirr sind, zusammengeschweißt wurden und die ganze Schweißtechnologie dazu. Das war ein ganzes Entwicklungsprogramm für sich, das überhaupt so bauen zu können. Wenn man das tatsächlich, diese gekrümmten Flächen, einfach perfekt aus dem Drucker haben könnte.
Und nicht nur gekrümmt, sondern eben halt auch das ganze Thema Kühlung, Wasserkühlung.
Stimmt, die Kühlkanäle direkt reindrucken.
Also das heißt, diese Hohlräume, da muss man ja wilde Verrenkungen, Rohrsysteme fügen und gefresen, also Kanäle fräsen und das wieder zusammenschweißen. Wenn man das alles als hohlraum fertigen kann, dann ist das schon auch ein Riesen-Kosten-Faktor, den man da einsparen würde.
Sind da so Kontakt mit den Leuten, die so was im raketenbau machen? Weil da ist ja gerade ziemlich viel, da passiert ja gerade viel. Die machen ja sowas wie die Kühlung von den Glocken, von den Triebwerken und die Pumpenbehäuse und so. Da gibt es jetzt so schon ziemlich so zwei oder drei Start-ups, die sogar schon fliegen mit irgendwie gedruckten Raketen. Also da scheint es ja sozusagen, der scheint ja nahe dran zu sein.
Also da gibt es zahlreiche Kontakte mit Industrie und mit, auch mit fraunhofer-instituten sind wir da schon unterwegs und haben da schon einmal die Übung gemacht, wirklich mal die ganze technische Spezifikation, diesen ganzen Freigabeprozess vom Design bis hin zur Einsetzbarkeit. Das ist ja ein langer Weg, auch ein langer technischer Weg, der gegangen werden muss. Und das ist auch ein formaler Weg. Was muss denn ja am Ende, hört sich mal komisch an, aber genehmigungsfähig sein. Also so, dass man dann auch nach innen sicher ist, dass das funktioniert. Da gibt es gute DIN-Normen dafür. Und diese DIN-Normen muss man dafür mal durchixen. Muss denn jeden einzelnen Schritt, den man machen. So was haben wir dann schon mal zusammen mit Industrien, mit fraunhofer, auch schon mal so angefangen durchzuixen. Da gibt es viel. Auch die privaten Startups, über die vielleicht auch noch reden, die sind da sehr, sehr aktiv an dieser Stelle, weil das natürlich auch verspricht, dass man ja auch andere Wege gehen kann und obendrein schneller und obendrein billiger. Das ist ja genau das Ding.
Und dann auf wiederum schneller teurieren kann.
genau. Und dann schnell Prototypen fertigen kann. Prototyping spielt auch natürlich eine Rolle. Also wir haben da jetzt schon mal so ein paar kleinere Komponenten, also so wissenschaftliche Instrumente, also das heißt gekühlte Platten und sowas, haben wir einfach schon mal so angefangen, mal zu fertigen, dass wir da mal so Erfahrungen sammeln und mal ein paar erste Schritte gehen. Die waren schon ganz ermutigend.
Ich muss noch eine Sache ansprechen. Wir haben ja gestern kurz am Rand gehabt, dass die Anlage vom TÜV abgenommen ist. Wie stellt man sich denn das vor?
Ganz komisch.
Das hat mich seitdem beschäftigt. Ich stelle mir vor, wie hier so eine Delegation vom TÜV vorbeikommt und so. Was ist denn das hier? Weil ich meine, das ist ja alles irgendwie die Unikarte.
Na ja, die kommen jetzt nicht in blaumann mit zum Hämmerchen. Aber das wird schon gut, oder?
Mit dem Schonaheimer. Klopfen, kloppen, kloppen.
Hält. Ja, also TÜV ist ja auch nicht gleich TÜV. Also es ist auch eine Riesenorganisation. In unserem Falle war, also wir haben alle TÜVs beschäftigt, TÜV Süd, TÜV Nord und TÜV Rheinland. Also alle großen TÜVs, es gibt auch ein paar kleinere noch. Und so für die eigentliche Abnahme der Anlage, die im Wesentlichen eine Strahlenschutzabnahme war. Denn das ist zwar keine nukleare Anlage, also keine kerntechnische Anlage, KTA heißt sowas denn. Das ist eine andere Klasse, die ist nach Atomgesetz genehmigt werden. Da wir keine kerntechnische Anlage sind, sondern eine Anlage sind, die ionisierte Strahlung freisetzt, müssen wir nach Strahlenschutzverordnung uns genehmigen lassen. Das macht dann eine Landesbehörde, das Lagust, das Landesamt für Gesundheit und Soziales. Und sie haben dafür eine Abteilung, die dann so Strahlenschutz macht, etwa Zahnärzte, wenn die so eine Röntgenanlage freigegeben haben wollen.
Ich wollte sagen, das ist aber eine andere Größenordnung, oder?
Ja, oder eben auch so kleine Beschleuniger in Kliniken. Das ist dann nicht so für Krebstherapie. Und eben halt, ja, spielt auch eine Rolle. In Rostock gibt es eine kleine Krebstherapieanlage etwa. Da gibt es natürlich die großen, dann Heidelberg und so weiter. Aber wenn wir jetzt mal für das Land das nehmen, also das heißt, da gibt es eine Landesbehörde, die sich dann beschäftigen muss. Und die Landesbehörde hat natürlich schon gesagt, ja, das hatten wir noch nicht. Und da brauchten da Sachverständige. Und da kommt der TÜV rein. Der TÜV ist ja ein Dienstleister. Diese Dienstleistung kann man kaufen. Und da ist eben eine Ausschreibung gemacht worden, eine bundesweite Ausschreibung. Und da hat der TÜV Rheinland den Zuschlag bekommen. Da hat er das beste Angebot gemacht. Und dann kam eben diese ganze Truppe vom TÜV Rheinland, dann waren es an. Das war eben halt so, dann waren das 2012, fingen dann dieser eigentliche richtige Prozess an, der intensive Prüfprozess, da war er schon zehn Jahre lang vorbereitet. Dann kamen die an und haben gesagt, naja, das ist jetzt in der Tat sehr prototypisch, das hatten wir auch noch nicht. Aber wir haben ja viel Erfahrung mit KTRs, also mit kerntechnischen Anlagen, mit Kernkraftwerken tatsächlich, aber auch Endlagerstätten und Beschleunigeranlagen, so Darmstadt haben die viel gemacht, die Schwerionbeschleuniger in Darmstadt. Dann fangen wir da mal an. Das heißt, wir nehmen alle voraussetzungen, die erfüllt werden müssen für eine kerntechnische Anlage und streichen alles weg, was für euch nicht relevant ist. So von oben nach dem anderen. Da kann man sich auch vorstellen, dann kommt man irgendwann in so einen graubereich, wo man sich dann trefflich streiten kann. Das war dann auch etwas mühsam, sich dann anzunieren. Und dann wurden am Ende Kriterien festgelegt, das heißt im Prinzip so eine Aufgabenliste bekommt man dann nicht. Also das müsst ihr alles machen und das muss alles geprüft werden, das muss alles nachgewiesen werden. Und dann müssen wir das eben prüfen, messen, nachrechnen. Auch Rechnungen sind erforderlich gewesen. An vielen Stellen müssen die dann vorlegen und dann werden die von der Landesbehörde mit Unterstützung des Sachverständigen dann geprüft und dann werden die Grünen gezeichnet, dann werden die freigegeben, wenn das denn überzeugend ist. Und das ist auch mit vielen Vorortterminen dann versehen. Das heißt also viele Besprechungen, aber auch richtig Vororttermine an den Apparaten, wo sich dann die Sachverständigen davon überzeugt haben, teilweise auch eigene Messungen gemacht haben.
Materialproben, Kernbohrungen.
Ja, das war noch eine andere Geschichte. Es war ein kleiner Schlenker dabei, das hätte nicht unbedingt sein müssen. Aber auf jeden Fall war das schon auch ein intensiver Prozess, wo man muss mal sagen.
Und die müsst ihr dann jedes Mal, wenn ihr größere Änderungen macht, dann ergänzen?
Wenn wir größere Änderungen machen, ja.
Deswegen machen wir erst mal keine.
Deshalb, die müssen immer mit der Behörde, die müssen angemeldet werden. Also es gibt Änderungen, die sind absehbar, die sind dann auch schon angemeldet. Und davon weiß die Behörde. Und dann sagen wir, okay, jetzt kommt diese Änderung. Jetzt da sind die Unterlagen dazu und dann werden die geprüft. Und dann wird das wieder entsprechend freigegeben, wenn alles in Ordnung ist. Also das ist schon ein sehr geregelter Prozess.
Und auch sehr streng. Also wir waren ja gestern in der Halle. Ich hab die Anordnung mehr oder weniger bekommen. Ich hab einen Schaltschrank, der jetzt nicht am Boden festgemacht war und das ist so nicht durchgegangen. Der muss sich dann nochmal quasi einfach im Boden festdübeln. Die Bohrung in den Boden rein, das ist ja eine Veränderung an der Strahlenschutzmaßnahme. Das heißt, die muss ich mir auch frei zeichnen lassen für die kleinen zwei Löcher, die ich da rein gemacht habe. Also die paar Gramm Beton, die ich da aus dem Boden ausgenommen hab. Und das ist nicht mal der Strahlenschutzboden, sondern der ist ja eine Etage tiefer. Aber wirklich jede kleine Änderung wird verfolgt und wird dann am Ende im Gesamtkontext dann auch bewertet. Das sind strenge Kriterien, die dann auch bei uns angelegt werden.
Gut, aber dient denn auch dem Schutz der hier Tätigen? Also ist ja in unserem ureigensten Interesse. Also nicht nur der Bürger, die rundherum wohnen. Also auch wenn man da sagen kann, da ist der Abstand auch schon wieder groß genug. Aber trotzdem insgesamt dient es dem Schutz aller Beteiligten rundherum und deshalb muss das ja auch ernst genommen werden. Deshalb ist die Strenge dieses Prozesses und die Systematik dieses Prozesses, dafür gibt es ja auch wieder wunderbare DIN-Normen und Gesetze und Regelungen, ist die sehr angemessen.
Noch mal so zurück zu der Frage, was wären so eure Wunschtechnologie-Durchbrüche? Also wenn ihr jetzt sagen könntet, okay wir haben jetzt mal drei Wünsche frei, außer additiven Manufacturing. Drei.
Also wir haben ja schon über hochtemperate Superlater besprochen, also wenn das bei mit Flüssig-Stickstoffkühlung zuverlässig und genauso gut läuft wie Neoptitan, wäre schon ein großes tolles Ding. 3D-Drucken, also additive manufacturing, wird auch das Leben an vielen Stellen einfach machen. Also eine dritte Schlüsseltechnologie ist ganz gewiss die Plasmaheizung, denn das ist ja quasi dieses Streichholz, mit dem man die Kerze entzündet. Das muss auch gut funktionieren. Diese Mikrowellengeneratoren, die sogenannten Gyrotrons, die wir haben, das sind auch so Meisterwerke.
Die waren letztes Mal gerade frisch. Und da habt ihr uns tolle Storys erzählt von wegen, was ihr da für Diamant besetzt oder irgendwie Spiegelsysteme gebaut habt.
Das sind auch Meisterwerke für sich. Das ist absolutes High-Tech. Und daran arbeiten wir zusammen mit dem, also führend auch mit dem KIT in Karlsruhe und mit der Industrie, mit der europäischen, aber auch US-Industrie, an besseren Lösungen, immer besseren Lösungen. Und wenn man da jetzt nochmal, da ist nochmal so ein Faktor 2, wieder bei hoher Zuverlässigkeit. Wenn ich Faktor 2 rede, nicht so Mikrowellen, so ein 2 Megawatt-Gyrotron. Das wäre schon cool. Und das macht einen qualitativen Unterschied. Unsere haben jetzt 1 Megawatt. Und da sagt man, aber 1 oder 2, das kann nicht so schlimm sein.
Na, aber ihr habt 2 davon. Also das heißt, das Ziel wäre jetzt...
Wir haben 10 davon.
Oh, wir haben 10. Wir haben 10 davon. Und wir sind jetzt dabei, uns 12 zu verschaffen. Und die zwei weiteren, da gehen wir schon in Richtung 1,5 Megawatt. Und dann würde man perspektivisch gerne alle 12 Steckplätze nicht überhaben. Es sind so wie Stecke, dass die Dinge eben halt übermannshoch sind. Also alle 12 Steckplätze durch 2 Megawatt versehen, das wäre schon schick. Aber wenn man sich dann mal wieder auf ein künftiges Kraftwerk ausdehnt, da braucht man so wahrscheinlich für einen Kraftwerk so etwas wie 50, 60 Megawatt. Und dann macht das schon einen Unterschied, ob dort 60 Stück rumstehen mit ihrer ganzen Infrastruktur, mit der Wasserkühlung und den ganzen Schaltpiperpro, oder ob sie immer 30 sind.
Jeweils auch mal so Bombeleitenmangeten.
Oder ob sie eben 30 sind. Und wenn man da vielleicht noch mal einen Sprung macht zu 3 Megawatt oder sowas, dann multipliziert sich das wieder runter. Aber die Technik an sich ist schon sehr gut, weil die ist eben sehr modular. Modularität ist ja mein Plus bei Technologie, dass nicht alles von einem großen Ding abhängt. Und dann würde man beim Kraftwerk, würde man dann so sagen, okay, ich brauche zum Anzünden des Plasmas brauche ich 50 Megawatt. Also brauche ich dafür dann entsprechend, wenn man dann 2 Megawatt Röhren hätte, brauche ich dann 25 Stück. Dann kaufe ich mir 30, dann läuft es auf jeden Fall. So, und dann hat man da eine Halle mit 30 solchen Röhren drin. Total solide Technik. Können auch ein paar Malade sein oder gerade in Wartung sein oder so was. Man kriegt es immer an. Und das ist auch so ein Robustheitsding. Hört sich vielleicht ein bisschen weniger sensationell an als 3D-Druck und Hochtemperatur-Superleiter. Aber manchmal bringt gerade ein solcher Faktor, also keine Größenordnung, ein solcher Faktor, schiebt das dann gerade in Richtung Praktikabilität.
Das ist dann quasi so ein leichter, quantitativer Unterschied, der schon einen qualitativen Sprung macht.
Ganz genau. Nämlich am Ende an Zuverlässigkeit. Also das Ding muss laufen, sonst kriegt man es nicht an. Man muss es wahrscheinlich sogar begleitend auch noch mitlaufen lassen für kleine Korrekturen und so was. Das ist wie so ein Steuerrad. Und das will man ja auch beim Auto nicht haben, dass das Steuerrad nicht geht.
Habt ihr denn so in den letzten Jahren den Fortschritt bei verfügbarer Computerleistung irgendwie praktisch bemerkt?
Na ja, da kann man auch schon sagen, der Vierte wünscht dir was. Aber da hab ich ein bisschen spitze Zähne auch manchmal. Natürlich kann man sich auch sagen, KI ändert alles. Und alle benutzen KI oder AI. Ja, klar. Viel. Also gerade bei den Codes, da gibt es enorme Beschleunigungsmöglichkeiten durch Verwendung von künstlicher Intelligenz. Im Prinzip ist das ja eine Art Fit-Algorithmus. Da werden so Dinge angepasst, aber eben durch so einen Lärmprozess, durch so ein Matching-Prozess, der da geschieht. Also überall, wo man etwas anpassen muss, wo man so Annäherungen machen muss, also in dem Sinne schnelle Konvergenzen erzeugen muss. Da kann KI enorm viel bringen. Das heißt, man kann auch mit Codes teilweise schwindelerregend beschleunigen. Dann gibt es KI-Ansätze, um etwa Stellaratorenoptimierung zu machen. vollautomatisch, nicht? Dann gibt es KI-Ansätze, um aus den manchmal komplexen Daten, die man da rausbekommt, da mehr zu machen und, und, und. Also das kommt auch auf breiter Front. In welchen Stellen das wirklich so einen qualitativen Unterschied ausmacht, das ist noch nicht, zumindest mir noch nicht so klar. Aber da muss man ein bisschen unterscheiden, was ist da von Hype und was bringt wirklich was?
Ich meine, was wir in vielen anderen Fällen sehen, ist halt einfach nur Produktivitätsgewinn. Also das man halt einfach mit in der selben Zeit mit, mit weniger Menschen mehr oder denselben Output erzielen kann. Und, meine ich, ihr habt ja auch viele Anforderungen, die dann halt sehr echt Zeit sind. Also man halt irgendwie so die Steuersysteme.
Und, und ansonsten schnelle Computer sind ja immer willkommen. Nicht so, also gerade auf dem Gebiet Simulation und, und Theorie. Und da ist für uns wahrscheinlich am wichtigsten die härteste Nuss. Also auch unsere Lieblings, Lieblingswissenschaftliche Nuss, also das Thema der Turbulenz zu knacken. Dafür braucht man einfach die schnellsten Computer, die man hat. Das ist zu komplex, um da mit, mit einfachen Modellen ran zu gehen. Die stimmen alle nicht, sondern man braucht sehr umfangreiche Modelle.
Die dann noch extrem hoch aufgelöst sind.
Die dann sehr gut aufgelöst sind, die aufgelöst sind. Also die Skalen sind unangenehm, sodass man da, wo man eben halt wirklich sehr massiv rechnen muss. Und da kommt es tatsächlich auf Computerpower und auf die schlauen Algorithmen an, also auf die Optimierung der Algorithmen an, dass man es machen kann. Und da ist man jetzt auch so gerade dran. Das heißt also, der beste Code, den so unser Institut entwickelt hat für das Thema Turbulenz, der rockt sich gerade zum Stellaratur vor. Also da konnte erst nur so einen, so einen kleinen lokalen Bereich, so ein schlauch nicht so im Stellaratur berechnen. Jetzt kann er schon eine Fläche berechnen. Und der nächste Schritt ist dann das Volumen rein. Und Turbulenz ist leider ein Volumeneffekt.
Das gleiche, was du gesagt hast, ist immer kurbisch, ja.
Beim Turkermark hat man noch das Schöne, dass man dann annäherungsweise Symmetrie quasi um die Tore, die die Richtung hat, weil...
Du kannst den Schnitt nehmen quasi.
genau, da kommt man für viele Probleme auch in der Turbulenz noch gut damit weg, dass man quasi eine ganze Dimension weglässt oder zumindest periodisch annähert und sagt, man nimmt sich nur eine kleine Scheibe letztendlich aus dem Turkanmark. Beim Stellarator muss man immer zumindest ein ganzes Modul, quasi eine Feldperiode, auch in drei Dimensionen mitnehmen. Und das macht es wirklich ekelig, wo die 3D-Simulationen jetzt gerade sind, die, also Turbulenzimulationen, die brauchen typischerweise so ein bis fünf Millionen CPU-Stunden, um quasi einen lauf durchlaufen zu lassen. Und der bringt einen dann meistens auch noch gar nicht so viel, wenn man vergleichen möchte, einen Parameterscan machen möchte, bei unterschiedlichen Dichten, unterschiedlichen Halsleistungen. genau, und das ist gerade so der Rand von dem, was gerade so möglich ist. Also da gibt es dann ganze Grants, die dann um eine Simulation rumgeschrieben werden, weil man die natürlich auf Supercomputern irgendwo laufen lassen muss. Das ist dann oft fast so ein paar Jahre wie ein eigenes Sexualment zu bauen. Das heißt, das sind schon irrsinnige Rechenleistungen, die da reingehen.
Das heißt also, wenn auf der Wunschliste wäre noch da drüben auf dem Feld noch ein Data Center mit Supercomputern und Papeter bei dran.
Wo die auch immer rumstehen.
Na gut, ja, klasse. Wo der Strom günstig ist.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, wir hatten ja kurz schon angerissen dieses Thema, so dieser Start-up-Hype, der ja passiert ist. Mein Eindruck war ja so ein bisschen, dass so der ITER so ein bisschen so die Ausbildungseinrichtung für die meisten von diesen Start-ups ist, weil quasi allen von denen sind ja zumindest Leute, die mal eine Weile am ITER gearbeitet haben oder da mal irgendwie an Experimenten die vorstaben und so. Aber so, dass wir jetzt diese kambrische Explosion von irgendwie allen möglichen Ideen in den letzten Jahren, ist ja schon eine Veränderung gegenüber jetzt noch vor sieben Jahren.
Naja, lustigerweise hatten wir letztes Mal auch ein Start-up besprochen. Also ein ähnlicher Start-up. Also da ging es um Northrop Grumman, die hatten gerade irgendwie ein großartiges Announcement gemacht und da ist so ziemlich still drum geworden, irgendwie, die wieder was vergehören.
Die Skunkworks-Geschichte da, ja.
Ja, aber inzwischen gibt es ja doch relativ viele. Gibt es irgendeinen davon, wo ihr denken würdet, ach, das wäre schon cool, wenn die mal herkommen und uns helfen?
Vielleicht zu dem Punkt, den du angesprochen hast. Die Diffusions-Community ist ja groß, aber nicht unendlich groß. Das heißt, wir haben alle mal irgendwo beieinander gearbeitet, was die öffentlichen Institute angeht. Und deswegen klappt man in den Start-ups immer Leute sitzen, die man irgendwie so kennt und mit denen auch mal was gemacht hat. Und dann kann man auch persönlich ihnen irgendwie gegenüberstehen und denken, ja, Mensch, du bist ein Idioter, schaff das eh nicht. Oder auch, ja, das ist sehr vielversprechend. Das kann in alle Richtungen gehen. Aber genau, am Ende, worum es bei den Start-ups ja immer geht, und das ist ja im Wesen des Start-ups drin, ist, dass sie irgendwas machen, was sonst keiner so richtig macht. Und mit einer Risikobereitschaft rangehen, die ich erstmal auch immer lobenswert finde. Also ich glaube, wir haben auch hier im Institut viele Leute, die die Start-ups skeptisch oder kritisch gegenüberstehen. Manchmal, wenn sie zu viel behaupten und man sich auch in der Öffentlichkeit dann auch als Institut da rechtfertigen muss oder auch korrigieren muss, ist es dann natürlich blöd und unangenehm. Aber grundsätzlich finde ich es super zu begrüßen. Also wenn das Geld dafür da ist und die Leute das Geld dafür in Anspruch nehmen. Und wichtiger Punkt für mich auch, wenn man mit den Ergebnissen dann auch offen umgeht und das auch mit der wissenschaftlichen Community bespricht und im besten Falle dann auch noch publiziert und teilt, dann gibt es einfach super viel zu lernen. Also es gibt viele alternative Fusionskonzepte, wo man grundsätzlich Kritik dran üben kann, wo wir auch intern im IPP auch viel zu gemacht haben, um uns auch selber davon zu überzeugen, dass wir wirklich mit unseren Konzepten da die richtige Spur verfolgen. Aber vieles ist halt nicht bekannt. Und oft muss man es einfach gemacht haben und im Experiment wirklich gezeigt haben, vielleicht auch nur, um unsere Meinung zu bestätigen, um zu sagen, ja, stimmt, es geht halt nicht. Ja, aber das sind am Ende oft Ressourcen, die wir an so einem großen öffentlichen Institut mit einer hauptsächlichen Mission einfach nicht haben oder ja nicht investieren wollen. Und wenn es dann jemand anderes macht, dann cool.
Habt ihr denn hier schon Ausgliederungen?
Ich würde es nicht den Ausgliederungen nennen, aber tatsächlich hat sich da so ein Grüppchen enthousiastischer junger Wissenschaftler da zusammengetan und haben einen Startup gegründet, ja. Jetzt gerade und längst.
Und da ist aber schon noch freundschaftliche Beziehung dann.
Das hat nicht, ganz im Gegenteil, dass er nicht zu einem Bruch geführt ist, sondern deren Konzept ist dediziert darauf angelegt, dass sie sehr eng mit uns zusammenarbeiten und gerade das Wissen, was hier in unserem Institut, also an beiden Standorten verfügbar ist, das in eine private Aktivität einbringen. Das ist natürlich auch nicht ganz unheikel, weil wir dürfen natürlich auch, einerseits ist unser Wissen, also das publizierte Wissen, das ist das Wissen der Menschheit. Das können alle haben. Das kann jeder benutzen. Dafür werden wir von Steuerzahlern natürlich bezahlt. Aber dann gibt es ja noch so ein spezifisches Wissen, was so in den Köpfen der Menschen ist und was nur durch deren Arbeitskraft auch umgesetzt werden kann. Und da wiederum dürfen, die dürfen wir nicht einfach einem Industrieunternehmen geben. Auch das geht ja mit Steuermitteln nicht. Das heißt, wir dürfen nicht plötzlich einfach für die arbeiten. Und insofern müssen da Verträge, sehr genaue Verträge ausgearbeitet werden, die dann so ein give-and-take festlegen. Also sind wir auch verpflichtet, also hier zuwendungsrechtlich verpflichtet, dass wir, wenn wir etwas leisten, dass wir dann mindestens das Gleiche wiederbekommen dafür, dass es neutral ist. Also das heißt, das ist ein freundliches, also das ist Teil von deren Konzept, dass sie eine sehr enge und fruchtvolle, freundlich-bauerfreundliche Beziehung dann zu uns halten und herstellen, die aber genau ausgearbeitet werden muss, damit wir nicht in einen rechtsfreien raum reinkommen. Und da müssen wir auch als Institution, als öffentliche Institution natürlich, Acht geben. Das ist für uns auch ein neues Feld. Das hatten wir noch nicht, nicht so in diesem Format. Da müssen wir auch Erfahrung sammeln, auch dann bekommen wir viel Unterstützung der gesamten Max-Planck-Gesellschaft dafür. Da haben wir eine Einrichtung, die heißt Max-Planck Innovation, die beide Seiten sehr genau berät. Unsere Juristen aus der Generalverwaltung helfen uns dort. Also das heißt, da arbeiten wir uns gerade vor. Es gibt in anderen Max-Planck-Instituten, etwa in der Quantenoptik, gibt es da schon so ein paar Schemata, also richtige Ausgründungen, die dann auch genau mit diesem Wissen sich ausgründen und dann auch ihre Weiterentwicklung mit Hilfe dieses Instituts, des MPQ, denn dort machen. Das heißt, man kann auch von anderen Mustern was lernen. Aber es ist neu.
Und was wollen die machen?
Die wollen Stellarator bauen. Mit Hochtemperatur-Superleiter.
Ah, okay, verstehe.
Und mit 3D-Drucken.
Das heißt, die gehen sozusagen in diese Richtung praktische Verwendbarkeit.
Also es gibt halt viele Metriken, viele Modelle, wie ein Stellarator zu optimieren ist, auch teilweise von unserer Theorie oder von den Physikern hier im Allgemeinen, ausgearbeitet und wie man quasi vereinfacht aufgrund von Plastmaparametern, aber auch tatsächlich Ingenieursparametern, dann ein Kraftwerk designen kann. Und oft sind dann diese, die Optimierung Schritte, die man letztendlich braucht, um dann am Ende zu einem wirklichen Design, also zu was baubaren zu kommen, das ist halt ganz viel händische Arbeit, ganz viel Zusammenkleistern von verschiedenen Optimierern, verschiedenen Modellen. Und das umzusetzen ist was, wofür es im Moment einfach nicht so richtig die Leute bei uns gibt. Und da ist die Idee, dass das quasi private Firma dann macht, also quasi mit dem vorhandenen Wissen und in Zusammenarbeit mit uns.
Und den Venture-Capital dafür einwirbt.
genau. Und wie sie, also haben sie auch erfolgreich eingeworben, und wie sie dann letztendlich sich als Firma etablieren, das liegt dann natürlich an ihnen. Das ist auch keine einfache Aufgabe, mit einem Institut wie uns dann zusammenzuarbeiten, natürlich diese Ergebnisse dann auch mit uns zu teilen. Und wie viel dann davon am Ende auch IP ist und wie viel von ihnen geschützt werden muss oder soll, das steht glaube ich im Detail noch aus. genau, aber es ist erstmal spannend, weil im besten Falle machen die ihr Dinge und liefern uns am Ende einen Design für einen Stellarator, den wir dann bauen könnten in Zusammenarbeit mit ihnen oder von ihnen beliefert. Oder wie das dann, wenn es vertraglich abläuft, weiß ich nicht. Aber ja, es ist cool erstmal und schön, dass es sowas gibt.
Und was werden das, sind das noch so andere Startups, die ihr so seht, wo ihr denkt so, ja könnte vielleicht irgendwie ganz cool werden.
Also wo viele Physiker gerade gespannt drauf gucken, ist tatsächlich Commonwealth Fusion. Also hatte ich ja vorhin schon als der superleiterbauer kurz erklärt, das ist eine Ausgründung oder eine Gründung neben dem MIT, also tatsächlich dann auch in Boston direkt oder in Cambridge. Und die bauen jetzt ein Hochfeld-Supra-Leiter, also Hochfeld-Hochtemperatur-Supra-Leiter-Turkermark, oder das ist ihr Ziel, und wollen auch sehr ambitioniert sehr bald schon die erste Maschine bauen. genau den Zeitplan weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht. Und arbeiten da sehr eng auch mit dem MIT, aber auch mit der gesamten Fusion Community zusammen, um dieses ambitionierte Projekt einfach irgendwie auf die Beine zu stellen, um zu sagen, wir bauen das Ding, egal wie irrsinnig das ist, und stellen uns einfach der technologischen Aufgabe, mit diesen irrsinnigen mechanischen Kräften auszukommen. Und gehen, das halte ich in zugute auch immer sehr offen, mit Kritik aus Seiten der Fusion Community um, wo wir halt Sorgen haben, also produktive Sorgen, weil wir ja auch wollen, dass das Projekt irgendwie gelingt. genau, die sind jetzt gerade dabei, ihre Halle zu bauen, und haben, wie gesagt, ihre erste Spule jetzt gebaut, ihre erste Spule auch schon kaputt gemacht. Und die lernen sehr, sehr schnell. Und das ist halt auch spannend zu sehen, wie sich, also auch aufgrund ihrer privaten Finanzierung, wie sich da auch ein anderer Druck ergebte jetzt nicht. Die müssen halt keine Forschungsergebnisse in dem Sinne liefern, sondern die müssen halt einen fertigen Druck am Arkt liefern. Und das ist spannend zu sehen.
Es ist ja so, dass man im öffentlichen Sektor inherent langsamer ist, weil man manche viele Dinge nicht darf. Das ist ja besonderes Geld, mit dem wir arbeiten. Das ist ja Steuergeld. Und Steuergeld, das ist vollkommen richtig. Der liegt ja in einer ganz besonderen Aufsicht. Es gibt das Bundesrechnungshöfe, da gibt es Vergaberecht, da gibt es Zuwendungsrechte. Und das alles regelt ja sehr genau den Umgang mit diesem Steuergeld, dass es dann sehr sorgfältig genau für seinen Zweck eingesetzt wird. Das hat ja eine Implikation auch in dem Blick auf Risikofreudigkeit. Wir sprachen da vorhin schon drüber. Also wir dürfen einfach kein zu großes Risiko eingehen, dass wir etwa Steuergeld in etwas investieren, eine Komponente in ein bauteil investieren, dann feststellen, das geht nicht. Sondern wir müssen alles dafür tun, sicherzustellen, dass das geht. Und so. Restrisiko bleibt immer, das kann man nicht ganz ausschließen, aber das muss immer prüffähig bleiben, sodass etwa ein Bundesrechnungshof, denn zum Schluss kommt, ja, mit diesem Steuergeld wurde vernünftig umgegangen, wurde sorgfältig konservativ umgegangen. Das geht natürlich aufs Tempo.
Das klingt jetzt so ein bisschen neidisch. Also wenn ich ein Start-up-Werk würde, würde ich jetzt hier tolle Sachen machen.
Also ich meine, es ist auch so, dass eine Anlage dieser Größenordnung, nicht wie sie hier jetzt steht, also dieses mal alles zusammenrechnet, weit über eine Milliarde Euro Projekt mit Vollkosten, aber auch die Investition von 400 Millionen in die Maschine, diese Anlage zu bauen. Unter diesem Regelwerk des öffentlichen Dienstes war alles andere als ein Spaß. Das passt auch nicht zusammen. Also wir haben es trotzdem irgendwie geschafft, aber es kostet Kraft und erzeugt innere Reibung. Und das ist die ganze Idee bei diesen Start-ups, dass sie sich davon befreien, dass sie eben mit Risikokapital, natürlich auch unter Aufsicht ihrer Kapitalgeber, das ist nicht völlig frei, aber mit diesem Risikokapital ganz anders umgehen können und einfach höhere Risiken eingehen können. Damit auch Entwicklungsrisiken eingehen können. Wie etwa so ein Commonwealth, die einfach diese Hochtemperatur-Superleitmagneten einfach mal gebaut haben. Und insofern ist das also ein interessantes zusätzliches Element in dem gesamten weltweiten Fusionsgefüge. Und da beginnt sich das jetzt so wieder zueinander neu auszurichten. Das muss ich ehrlich sagen, ist auch eine Überraschendentwicklung. Vor fünf Jahren hätte ich das nicht gesagt, dass das so signifikant wird. Also ist tatsächlich so eine kambusche Explosion. Aber auch genau in diesem Sinne, es gibt auch blöde Startups. Also die wirklich...
Das wäre gleich die nächste Frage. Also wir sind ja allein auf dem Gebiet, aber für mich sieht das immer aus, irgendwie tolle Ankündigungen und dann eine Weile nichts mehr.
Das ist natürlich supernervig, wenn das passiert. Ich hab nicht probiert, vorsichtig auszudrücken, vor allem mit den Positivwahlspielen, die auch auf Feedback eingehen. Es gibt Projekte, die behaupten irgendwas, dann hört man nichts und dann hört man nichts. Aber das sind trotzdem Dinge, auf die wir gerade in der Öffentlichkeit dann irgendwie reagieren müssen, weil wir mit unseren behauptungen dann halt dagegen stehen und sagen, ja, wenn die behaupten, sie können in fünf Jahren ein Fusionskraftwerk bauen, warum können wir das nicht? Zum Teil kann man das relativ einfach abbügeln und sagen, ja, das Konzept ist einfach bekloppt und wir haben überhaupt keinen Plan, wie sie irgendwie zu dieser fertigen Maschine in der kurzen Zeit kommen wollen. Aber oft ist das sehr viel subtiler. Oft ist da halt auch viel Physik drin. Und wir haben uns da auch hier im Institut die Möglichkeit gegeben, die tatsächlich auch allemal physikalisch durchzuführen. Also tatsächlich hatten wir dazu eine kleine Veranstaltungsreihe. Einfach, um uns selber klar zu machen. Also nicht nur mit irgendwelchen Handwaving-Argumenten. Ich glaub, da schafft man nicht. Sondern wirklich zu sagen, weil dieser Verlustkanal viel zu groß ist, weil bewiesen ist, dass mit diesen Magnetfeldkonfigurationen nicht klappen kann. Weil es diese Materialien nicht gibt. genau, sind wir überzeugt, dass dieses Konzept vielleicht nicht Schwachsinn, aber einfach nicht im...
Vor großer herausforderung steht.
genau, vor großer herausforderung steht, wo nicht klar ist, dass es irgendwie so ein Silver-Bullet geben kann, was dann irgendwie ein geheimes Start-up-Technologie ist, die aus dem Militärbereich kommt oder was auch immer. genau, und das ist auch zum Teil unsere Aufgabe, dass wir das halt mit bewerten. Aber zum Teil ist es auch einfach echt anstrengend.
Im Prinzip wie dieses Rätselheft, wenn man das Rätselheft findet, den Fehlern.
Das ist für Menschen, die jetzt von Plastophysik keine Ahnung haben, sehr schwierig. Also eines, das war unser Hörer, kommt war halt Helion, weil die relativ viel publik machen und auch schon ein paar Testsysteme gebaut haben und so relativ schnell voraninterieren. Was denke ich zu denen? Haben die eine Chance oder ist das...
Helion, was war denn mit den zwei Field Reverse Configurations, die sich ineinander scheppern?
genau, diese Handtülle, wo sie halt die zwei Tore untereinander ziehen.
Spannend, aber ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht. Also hatten wir auch dann in dieser Vortragsreihe, also der Fuelzyklus ist überhaupt nicht klar, den sie haben. Also was wollen sie für Materialien nehmen, die tatsächlich dann fusioniert werden? Was wir dann ausbekommen haben, einfach von so einfachen Bilanzrechnungen, was man dort fusioniert, dann im Endeffekt in einem Fusionskraftwerk dieser Art, ist, dass man relativ schnell sehr große Mengen Trizium vor Ort hat. Man hat so lauter technologische Folgeprobleme, die sich quasi aus einem kraftwerksbau dann ergeben würden von dem Prinzip. Und es gibt noch ein paar Fundamentalpunkte, die mir so gar nicht klar sind. Zum Beispiel diese zwei Plasmen, die ineinander geschossen werden, die müssen dann zusammen komprimiert werden. Dazu wird ein sogenannter Plasma-Liner benutzt. Das ist ein schweres Gas, was in ein Plasma-Zustand versetzt wird und dann tatsächlich mechanisch irgendwie reinkomprimiert wird, um dann letztendlich diese beiden reaktiven Gas, die diffusioniert werden sollen, um die Plasmen dann weiter zusammen zu komprimieren. Und da ist die Physik einfach auch noch so gar nicht klar. Ich glaube, die wollen Xenon benutzen und die ganze Xenon-Physik ist auch ganz irrsinnig. Und soweit ich weiß, machen die das auch noch gar nicht. Das heißt, sie sind jetzt erst an einem Punkt, wo sie diese zwei Field-Reverse-Configurations, also die beiden Initialplasmen gegeneinander beschleunigen und dann zeigen, dass das funktioniert. Das ist auch cool. Aber dann gibt es halt noch ein paar sehr große physikalische und technologische Fragen, die sich dann erst ergeben, wenn sie in ihren Prototypen dann in Richtung tatsächliche Fusionsmaschine dann gehen wollen. Das heißt nicht, dass sie es auf keinen Fall schaffen, aber es sind halt Fragen, die auch erst mal komplett unbeantwortet sind. Es gibt halt keine Publikationen von denen.
Also aus dem, was du jetzt so sehen kannst, die fünf Jahre, die sie jetzt so angesagt haben, eher für optimistisch.
Das finde ich hier sportlich.
Gibt es denn so Fälle, die man sich anguckt und sagt, auf die Idee hätten wir auch kommen können? Also wo klar ist, dass es irgendwie eine gute Idee ist. Das probieren wir auch mal aus.
Also es wurde schon sehr viel gemacht, muss man auch sagen. Also es war ja ein sehr schmerzhafter Weg am Ende beim Programm Agoncellarator anzukommen. Und da hat sich die ganze Fusionsforschung auch oft nicht besonders mit Ruhm bekleckert und irrsinnige Anlagen gebaut, wo sich dann auch teilweise im bau dann ausgestellt hat, weil die Theorie einfach die Anlage überholt hat und man gesagt hat, das geht prinzipiell nicht.
Also es wurde in der Tat unglaublich viel schon ausprobiert. Und viele von den neuen Konzepten oder etliche von diesen neuen Konzepten, die sind noch schon mal 1960, 1950, manchmal 1970 schon mal komplett durchgekaut worden. Da kann man immer sagen, na vielleicht hat man ja was übersehen.
Oder es gibt diesen einen coolen Trick, wir verbinden einfach zwei von diesen Konzepten und dann funktioniert das unglaublich viel besser.
Also du machst eine Kombination daraus, aber das ist bisher alles nicht überzeugend. Nicht so, als ob man das aus der Mottenkiste wieder rausholt und sagt, na vielleicht geht es doch. Das geht sowieso nicht, weil die Physik hat sich inzwischen nicht verändert.
Aber es gibt ja neue Materialien, es gibt bessere.
Ja, und das wird dann manchmal gesagt, schnellere Computer, nicht andere Materialien, aber so viel verändert das dann auch nicht. Wenn die Physik nicht mitmacht, dann können die Computers schnell sein, wie sie wollen, dann ändert das nichts. Und diese Ansätze, wie da Knoten durchschlagen werden, die schon immer da wären, die fehlen sehr oft. Wo man wirklich sagt, genau in dem Sinne, da haben wir was übersehen, wir trotteln.
Da wartet ihr auch noch drauf, wer das so will.
Es gibt hier und da mal Ecken, wo man sagt, naja, da hat eine technische Entwicklung jetzt etwas weiter vorangebracht, so dass es wert ist, das nochmal anzugucken. Aber trotzdem fängt man da wieder 1960 an und hangelt sich dann wieder durch diese ganze Kette von Problemen durch. Also wie Adrian ja dargestellt hat, der Forschungsweg der Fusion ist ja auch ein langer Leidensweg, von vielen Fehlschlägen und Enttäuschung. Dann hat sich so in so einem Darwinistischen System, hat sich dann so übrig geblieben von dieser ganzen großen Gemeinde, eben halt eigentlich diese beiden Einschlusskonzepte. Nicht Tuckermack und Stellarator.
Zwei stehen noch.
Zwei stehen noch, nicht so. Und alles das, was da auf dem Weg, auf der Strecke geblieben ist, ist mit gutem Grund auf der Strecke geblieben. Wenn man diese Gründe nicht fundamental beseitigt, da kann man nicht einfach mal so Handwaving sagen, Computer sind schneller geworden, das kauf ich nicht oder Materialien sind irgendwie besser geworden. Also das trifft nicht den Kern der Sache. Und das gehört dann alles eigentlich in den Bereich, wo man doch große Fragezeichen ranmalen soll. Also die Start-ups, die wir jetzt auch so positiv diskutiert haben, die gehen eigentlich, also die sind eigentlich auch wieder relativ konservativ. Nicht so, das heißt, die gehen die hauptlinie, aber bringen in diese hauptlinien neue technologische Elemente rein.
Und Geschwindigkeit und Kapital.
Und Geschwindigkeit, also eigene Flexibilität und Kapital und vielleicht ein oder zwei wohl definierte, wohl ausgewählte neue Elemente wie Hochtemperatur, Superleitung, wie 3D-Drucken. So sind nicht zu viel aufeinander häufen und einfach nicht das Prinzip Hoffnung zu sehr belasten.
Das muss jetzt klappen.
Das Problem ist auch tatsächlich ein Größenordnungsproblem. Also wenn man auch Experimente gebaut hat nach einem bestimmten Konzept und dann feststellt, dass man irgendwie sechs Größenordnungen entfernt ist von den Einschlusszeiten oder den Parametern, die man braucht, um tatsächlich zu einem Fusionskraftwerk zu kommen, dann hilft halt ein Faktor 5 nicht in irgendwie ein neuem Material, was man gefunden hat, oder der eine coole Trick, den man jetzt irgendwie durch neue Supercomputer lösen kann. Sondern man ist halt immer noch fundamental weit weg. Und da sind wir halt beim magnetischen Einschluss, also beim Tokamak und beim Stellarator, relativ nah dran. Also da ist der Weg sehr viel klarer, wie man dahin kommt. Und es fehlt halt nur noch ein kleiner Faktor und halt nicht mehr die Größenordnungen, die bei den alternativen Konzepten halt oft da sind, wo der Weg dann einfach auch nicht klar ist, wie will man überhaupt hinkommen.
Türkisch ist dabei ja auch, dass es gar nicht so schwer ist, Fusion an sich zu machen. Das haben wir auch letztes Mal schon gesehen. Aber eben halt viel Fusion, genug Fusion, damit wirklich ein Überschuss entsteht. Und da muss eben der Weg, wie Adrian eben gesagt hat, der Weg muss klar sein, wie man von etwas zu viel gehen kann, wie das skalierbar ist, wie man es hoch skalieren kann. Wenn man nur mal so ein bisschen demonstriert, ey, da passiert was, dann ist das gleich eine tolle Pressemitteilung wert, Fusion gelungen. Aber das nützt gar nichts, wenn es nicht extrapolierbar ist, wenn es nicht skalierbar ist. Die Skalierbarkeit, das muss jede, jeder Fusionsansatz muss die Skalierbarkeit demonstrieren.
Das war ja so was, was bei dieser National Ignition Facility, das fand ich ja so dreist, irgendwie wie sie einfach ihre Wasserstoffbombenforschung irgendwie plötzlich zum Fusionskraftwerk umdeklariert haben.
Obwohl, wenn man die Pressemitteilung unserer Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort liest, dann sind die superehrlich.
Okay, die sagen, wir machen den Jungs ab.
Ja natürlich, die sind ja auch sofort beruflos, wenn die da überhaupt nicht sind.
Also das war komplett korrekt. Die sagen, ja, sie studieren warme, warme, dichte Materie, auch mit einer Relevanz für die Waffenforschung. Und guck mal, wir haben ja einen großen wissenschaftlichen Durchbruch erlangt. Was stimmt? Das war schon ein Kunststück. Da haben wir zehn Jahre lang gearbeitet. Dass tatsächlich dieser Neutronenergieüberschuss größer war, als die Energie, die man vor Ort in diese Pille reingesteckt hat, also in diese Kapsel hineingezaubert hat. Wir haben nicht gesagt, das wird ein Kraftwerk übermorgen.
Aber das war ja dann so die politische Darstellung.
Also manchmal war es die Wahrnehmung, manchmal wieder Wunschdenken. Also leider spielt ja bei den Menschen Wunschdenken eine große Rolle. Also die Not ist ja groß, neue Energiequellen zu eröffnen. Und man hätte das lieber morgen als heute. Geht mir auch so.
Das wollen wir auch noch ansprechen. Ob ihr nicht so irgendwie Druck spürt, dass die Gesellschaft euch so in den Nacken atmet. Wo bleibt denn ihr?
Doch, absolut.
Wie viel kommt ihr da hin? Kommt ihr einmal pro Woche in Lokalpolitik an? Manche Jungs, jetzt macht mal ein bisschen.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall die häufigste Frage bei Führungen. Also wann ist es denn so weit?
Macht doch mal hin.
Na, wenn es nur die Lokalpolitiker wären. Also da passiert schon viel jetzt gerade. Also auch nicht nur an Frage, sondern auch wirklich an Forderung, würde ich schon so sagen, mich jetzt mal Gas geben.
Sitzt denn da auch das Geld dann lockerer als sonst? Oder ist, ich meine, ich sehe halt, wie die dieses Flüssiggas-Terminal da mal eben aus dem Boden stampfen. Das riecht ja schon so ein bisschen nach Verzweiflung. Und da hätte ich mir gedacht, okay, dann sind bestimmt auch ein paar Milliarden übrig, um hier mal in die Fusionsforschung zu investieren.
Na, schauen wir mal. Also es ist nicht mehr ganz, ich will es mal so formulieren, es ist nicht mehr ganz so absurd, wie es noch vor, beim letzten Mal, noch vor fünf Jahren erschienen wäre. Also man merkt schon, dass der Handlungsdruck viel größer geworden ist. Ob der reicht, um wirklich den Schritt zu einer konkreten Handlung zu machen, das steht auf einem anderen Blatt. Aber wir spüren einen ganz anderen politischen Wind. Der hat interessanterweise auch mit den Start-ups zu tun.
Weil es möglich erscheint.
Ja, weil es am Ende auch das vertrauen in die Machbarkeit erhöht hat.
Wenn Bill Gates da Geld investiert, dann wird da was dran sein, so?
Ja, sozusagen, im dem Sinne. Das heißt, es kann nicht völliger Unfug sein. Oder rein akademisches Vor-sich-hin-Puzzeln. Wir haben ja schon immer versucht zu vermitteln, dass wir gesagt haben, wir glauben, es könnte klappen. Das heißt, wir spüren schon. Wir riechen es schon. Nicht so, nicht so. Aber da kann man sagen, na ja, nicht was die so glauben. Aber es hat eine viel breitere Basis bekommen. Und das hat auch was verändert in dem politischen Umfeld und auch im wirtschaftlichen Umfeld, im Wahrnehmungsumfeld. Das merken wir sehr stark. Und das hat natürlich auch der Grund, dass man festgestellt hat, jetzt also hier Stichwort russisches Gas. Dass wir einfach enorme politische Abhängigkeiten von den Fossilen haben. Das heißt also, Fossile haben nicht nur den Nachteil, dass sie unser Klima ramponieren, sondern sie haben auch den Nachteil, dass es ein riesenpolitisches Druckmittel ist, dass wir andere Wege finden müssen. Und natürlich muss man mit aller Kraft in die Erneuerbaren reingehen, mit allem, was geht. Und dann kommt immer noch die Frage, ist es wirklich alles, was wir haben? Und dann ist am Ende bloß noch die Fossilien übrig, als die einzige noch nicht genutzte Primärenergiequelle. Alle anderen Fässer sind schon geöffnet und in Benutzung.
Und wenn jetzt mal so hypothetisch, da gibt es ja noch eine ganze Menge Detailprobleme zu lösen. Also sowas wie irgendwie, wie lange hält denn eigentlich das Material durch? Wie wirkt man eigentlich die?
Also nicht nur Details, ne? Also es sind große herausforderungen.
Ja, die Teilprobleme war jetzt in Anführungszeichen so. Also, weil so, was ich so mitbekommen hatte, Materiärstabilität unter Neutronenfluss, wie kriegt man eigentlich die Hitze da weg und macht dann da halt irgendwie Strom draus? Was habt ihr da noch so auf der Liste?
Na, das war ja doch fast technisch gelöst, aber irgendwie, ich hatte noch als offen auf der Liste, dass das Material halt schlecht wird, wenn man da halt...
Das war, sagte ich ja gar nicht.
Nee, aber also wie man die Energie da rauszieht, das war eigentlich, dachte ich nicht. Ist das gelöst?
Ah, also es ist schon insgesamt so ein ganzer Komplex. Also diese, ja, also die Kombination, das Wärmeabfuhr und Neutronenfluss, die ist schon mehr als unangenehm. Denn unter starkem Wärmeeintrag werden Materialien halt heiß, ja. Das ist auch alles tolerabel, also 500 bis sogar 1000 Grad kann man alles. Das ist ja wie so die erste Wand von so einem Brennofen. Der ist auch zwischen 500 und 1000 Grad, nicht? Wenn man so ein Gasbrennofen hat oder so was, ist alles nicht so schlimm. Aber wenn man dann noch die Neutronenflüsse dazu kombiniert, das ist ja, das Material ist ja durch diese, durch die Wärme, also durch die Oberflächentemperatur schon in dem Sinne geschwächt, kann man sagen. Also ist ja angreifbarer. Die Atomverbünde sind nicht mehr so, nicht mehr so fest wie eben halt unter raumtemperaturbedingungen. Dann werden sie so bombardiert mit solchen Bällen. Das heißt also der Materialabtrag nimmt enorm zu. Auch so die Fähigkeit einzudringen nimmt enorm zu und so weiter. Und die ganze Stabilisierung der Materialien, das heißt die lebensdauer und die Festigkeit der Materialien ist da schon schlechter, wenn man diese Kombination hat. Und da muss man natürlich stark mit der Materialforschung einsteigen. Und da hat man jetzt erst mal so eine Forschungsinfrastruktur, auch eine Archilis-Ferse, da haben wir zu wenig Testmöglichkeiten.
Also wir können ja stark Neutronenquellen haben, wo man mal 1000 Grad heiße Materialien danebenhalten kann.
Ja, es gibt zwar Neutronenquellen, aber es kommt sehr auf die Geschwindigkeit der Neutronen an, also auf das Geschwindigkeitsspektrum der Neutronen. Denn wenn man etwa jetzt zu diesen Neutronenquellen, die es alle gibt für Materialforschung in München, dann ist da der FM2, dann gibt es in Petten den Hochflussreaktor für Materialforschung. Also mit Neutronen macht man viel Materialforschung. Aber das sind alles so thermische Neutronen, die also viel langsamer sind, moderiert sind, die relativ langsam so daherkommen. Und wir brauchen ja, bei uns entstehen ja die Elektronen so im Mega-Elektronen-Volt-Bereich.
Neutronen.
Was soll ich sagen?
Elektronen.
Oh, sorry, Neutronen. Ja, gute Korrektur, danke. Also Neutronen im Mega-Elektronen-Volt-Bereich. Dafür muss man wieder dedizierte Anlagen aufbauen, die solche Neutronen erzeugen, sodass man dann damit tatsächlich Materialien bearbeiten kann, um den richtigen Materialmix zu finden. Also Materialforschung ist ja in der Tat so, dass man da ein sehr wissenschaftliches Gestäut ist, aber trotzdem Trial-and-Error machen muss, nicht? Das heißt, man muss verschiedene Kombinationen ausprobieren. Man muss, das kann man nicht rechnen. Da gibt es keine Formeln dafür. Dann sagt man, das ist es. Sondern da muss man tatsächlich sehr viel testen. So eine Testanlage ist über Jahrzehnte diskutiert worden. Jetzt sind wir so weit, dass wir in Europa tatsächlich so einen auf die Beine stellen werden. Ich glaube, in Malaga ist das. Ja, also in Spanien auf jeden Fall.
War ITAN nicht auch mal geplant als Testbed für sowas?
Äh, ist es. In dem Sinne, aber es ist halt keine...
Kommt halt nicht voran oder wie?
Nein, das Problem ist eher, das ist quasi schon das fertige Ding. Also man kann, man muss, auch bei ITA muss man ja relativ konservativ bleiben. Und an ITA werden zum Beispiel ganz stark getestet, verschiedene Konzepte zur Tritiumgewinnung. Das heißt, wie man aus den Neutronenflüssen letztendlich aus seinen Wandmaterialien dann das Tritium zaubert, was man dann wieder braucht, um die Funktionsreaktionen zu machen. Aber da kann man sich nicht erlauben, irgendwie ganz wilde Sachen zu machen, welche Materialien zu zerschießen, sondern das Ding muss halt als Reaktor funktionieren. Das heißt, man hätte schon gerne, und das entsteht jetzt zum Glück auch, eine Anlage, wo man gezielt einfach Materialien unter Laborbedingungen dann auch testen kann.
So reinhält.
genau, also ja, tatsächlich einfach reinhält, mit mal Brunnen beschießt und dann schaut, was passiert denn damit.
Wie gut kann man denn Vorhersagen treffen? Denn es kann ja sein, also bei den Kernspaltungsreaktoren haben wir ja jetzt 50 Jahre später, oder es sind aber Risse im Beton. Das kann ich ja nicht irgendwie durch einmal reinhalten sehen, dass da nach 50 Jahren Risse entstehen, oder?
Die Langzeitbeständigkeit, das ist immer ein Thema bei so was. Also egal, was man macht, ob man eine Brücke baut, oder eine Straße baut, oder ein Kernkraftwerk, oder ein Fosionskraftwerk, oder ein Flugzeug nicht. Also Langzeitbeständigkeit von Materialien ist ein dauerbrenner. Das findet man nur raus, indem man es mal tut, und dann eben halt Erfahrungen damit sammelt. So macht die Flugzeugindustrie dann auch nicht. Das heißt, wenn du etwa hier auf Airbus jetzt oder Boeing auf solche Verbundmaterialien setzt, um quasi die ganzen Flügel aus Plastik zu bauen, dann wissen sie auch erst, ob das Flugzeug 20 Jahre lang hält, wenn das 20 Jahre lang geflogen ist. Das ist nicht berechenbar, das ist kaum testbar, das ist nur eingeschränkt testbar, das ist nicht vorhersagbar. Das heißt, da sitzen wir in einer Liga so drin. Das heißt, da muss man einfach die Erfahrungen sammeln und dann am Ende versuchen, konservativ zu sein. Aber wichtig ist, dass man überhaupt erst mal so ein Testprogramm auflegt und wirklich mal fundamental verschiedene Materialkombinationen durch x. Und dafür ist also diese Testanlage sehr, sehr wichtig. Und wie gesagt, die wird jetzt auf dem Weg gebaut, wird in Spanien gebaut, wird alles auch ein paar Jahre dauern. Das heißt, da sitzen wir auch schon wieder in den 30er Jahren. Parallel dazu gibt es natürlich diese komplementären Untersuchungen an ITER, die die Adriane ja dargestellt hat. Das sind sogenannte Testblanket-Einheiten, die also so in den Labors entwickelt werden. Und dann, wenn ITER läuft und Neutronen erzeugt, die dann dort so in Kassetten so eingesetzt werden. Und dann kann man damit diese Trizium-Erzeugung und auch im Ende diese Beständigkeit der Wand schon mal ein bisschen so erkunden. Unsere chinesischen Kollegen, die haben das Problem auch sehr wohl erkannt. Und die haben auf dem Weg einen Tokamak alleine für diese Material, also für diesen Wandtest aufzubauen mit hohem Neutronenfluss. Also nur um die, also nur ein Gänsefüßchen, um genau diese Frage zu klären. Also es ist schon so, dass das Problem erkannt ist, aber es ist am Ende der Nahrungskette.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir irgendwie in zehn Jahren den Stellaratur fertig haben und dann stellen wir fest, wir wissen gar nicht, wie man Mantel bauen soll? Weil das wäre schon doof, kann man da irgendwie Erfahrungen aus den normalen Kernkraftwerken verwenden?
Leider nicht, weil das Neutronenspektrum so unterschiedlich ist. Und außerdem auch dieses Trizimbrüten ist auch keine Trivialität. Also da ist ein technologisches Restrisiko drin. Das kann man nicht völlig negieren, dass man sagen kann, da kann man noch mal ins Stolpern kommen.
Aber um direkt deine Frage zu beantworten, also natürlich gibt es da Forschung und Untersuchungen und Pläne. Also gerade auch an ITER sind sieben verschiedene Konzepte, an Blank-Ed-Modulen, die gleichzeitig getestet werden. Ja, aber man hat es halt noch nicht gemacht, weil man hatte halt noch keinen Fusionsreaktor.
Da ist ja Wissenschaft ja zum Glück streng. Also das heißt, es kann erst eine Hakenländer gemacht werden, wenn es wirklich demonstriert ist. Also jetzt gibt es eben jede Menge Konzepte, sehr vernünftige Voruntersuchungen, Ideen und so weiter. Und bis jetzt sieht man keinen wirklich harten Showstopper. Und man sieht jede Menge Hürden, also jede Menge so Knackpunkte, die dort zu uns schiffen sind. Und dafür muss man es machen, um Gottes Namen. Also ich bin auch kein Freund davon, dass man die Flinte schon vorher ins Korn wirft. Also solche Stimmen gibt es auch, die sagen, dass Tritiumbrüten zu schwierig ist, wir können den ganzen Kram lassen. Aber das finde ich ist zu depressiv.
Ja, für mich wäre mir auch keine Alternative, was soll man denn denn machen?
Ja, also das finde ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen feige. Dann lassen wir es gleich von vorne rein, das ist mir zu schwierig.
Zumal ja im Zweifel auf dem Weg auch neue Ideen auftauchen.
Ja eben, also man lernt was ja nur indem man es macht. Das ist ja wie mit den Maschinen bauen. Also diese großen Fusionsanlagen bauen. Man lernt die zu bauen, indem man sie baut. Dabei macht man jede Menge Fehler, über hat man jede Menge technische Krisen, jede Menge Rückschläge. Aber danach ist man viel schlauer. Also jetzt, nachdem wir dieses Ding da gebaut haben, wissen wir viel besser, wie man das Ding hätte bauen sollen.
Und was sind jetzt noch so, außerhalb dieses Materialermüdungen und Fühlungen, was sind jetzt noch so die großen Blöcke, wo man so sagt, da gibt es noch erhebliche technologische Risiken, außer der allgemeinen Komplexität?
Also wenn man sich ein bisschen zurücklehnt, dann muss man systemisch betrachtet als Systemkraftwerk, muss man auf jeden Fall dafür sorgen, dass die, also hier, dass die Verfügbarkeit hoch ist und dass die Wartbarkeit hoch ist. Denn das ist eine riesen Investition, das sind Großanlagen, müssen Großanlagen sein, im Miniaturformat, so im Megawattformat oder so was, ist nicht absehbar, dass man das mit der jetzigen Technologie auf die Beine stellt, das ist immer mehrere hundert Megawatt mindestens. Das sind also Großanlagen, Großanlagen werden immer teuer sein per Natur, allein schon wegen Volumen. Magnetfeld bezahlt man nach Volumen, Stahl bezahlt man nach Volumen, Beton bezahlt man nach Volumen, wird also teuer sein. Teuer wird eine große Investition, damit eine große Investition. Wirtschaftlich ist, muss sie abgeschrieben werden und dann Profit erzeugen, das heißt, das Ding muss laufen, das darf nicht down sein. Wenn man dann so was wie 50 Prozent Down-Zeit hat, dann beginnt das auch schon wirtschaftlich zu kippen, was durchaus nicht unkritisch ist, weil man so viele Hightech-Sachen miteinander verbindet, die alle versagen können, die alle wackelig sein können, das heißt, man muss es viel, viel robuster machen. Das heißt, die Betriebszeit, die muss man nach oben peitschen, durch wirklich sehr, also manchmal auch durch Redundanzen und durch sehr gut getestete und sehr bewährte technologische Elemente, das heißt, hohe Zuverlässigkeit, vielleicht wie bei so einem Flugzeug oder so was. Und dann die Wachbarkeit, das heißt, man hat ja diese Down-Zeit, letztlich auch um diese erste Wand auszuwechseln. Diese Neutronen, beschossene und wärmebelastete Wand, irgendwann muss man, muss die raus. Und das wird man in einem bestimmten Zugluss machen müssen, jährlich oder alle zwei Jahre, nicht so irgendwo in dem Korridor. Aber dann darf das auch nicht zwei Jahre dauern. Also dann muss das flott gehen. Und die Techniken, und das in einem nuklearen Umfeld, da kann man nur mit Robotern rumfahren. Da kann man keine Menschen reinschicken, die dann das so rausschrauben und rauskarren. Sondern da kann man nur mit Maschinen arbeiten. Und der maschinenbau dafür, der hat's auch in sich. Der ist nicht ohne. Also das ist jetzt auch wieder so was, wo man sagen könnte, naja, das ist ja alles machbar, und das kriegt man dann hin, wenn man sich genügend Zeit lässt. Aber wenn die Down-Zeit 50...
Die haben wir halt nicht, die Zeit.
Ja, aber auch für einen Betreiber. Nicht wenn die Down-Zeit von einem solchen teuren Kraftwerk, wenn die 50 Prozent ist. Das heißt, wenn man für den Wartungszyklus so viel wie den laufzeit hat, dann ist das einfach unwirtschaftlich.
Ein Aspekt davon ist auch die öffentliche Wahrnehmung davon. Also man merkt das ja in Kernkraftwerken, wenn die längere Reparaturphasen haben und wegen Kühlwasser über Temperatur dann zum Teil nicht funktionieren können. Ja, da ist der Hohengleich total groß, weil natürlich ein Kernkraftwerk von sich behauptet, dass es halt ständig laufen kann. Es kommt locker für ein beliebiges Kernkraftwerk mal zu. 30-40 Prozent Downtime und das... Also darunter leidet natürlich das Kernkraftwerk auch wirtschaftlich, aber auch in öffentlichen Wahrnehmungen sieht das dann nicht mehr so aus wie was, was halt immer zur Verfügung steht.
Also da ist noch allerlei hausaufgaben zu machen. Also dieses Hightech robust zu machen. Also wir segeln da ja sehr an der Grenze, so das technisch machbare, also das klassischen Hightech, was so gerade eben geht. Und selbst wenn man das gerade eben dann zum laufen bringen würde, ist das noch nicht automatisch attraktiv für einen wirtschaftlichen Betrieb, weil es dann noch zu sensibel ist, zu ausfallsensibel ist, zu lange braucht, um die Wartung durchzuführen, um die Betriebsfähigkeit sicherzustellen. Das heißt, da muss man es einfach sehr, sehr robust machen. Aber am Ende ist das fast wie immer in der Technikgeschichte.
Production Engineering halt.
Ja, eben wie immer in der Technikgeschichte. Der First of a Kind, der ist immer ganz schrecklich noch. Und dann muss man einfach weitermachen. Dann muss man am Ball bleiben, weitermachen. Und dann wird das automatisch konservativ.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein ganzer Themenkomplex, der bei Physikern jetzt nicht super beliebt ist. Aber macht man sich halt irgendwie ungern Gedanken.
Das ist bei Hardware-Engineers genauso. Oder bei Production-Engineers die andere Spezies.
Man will natürlich seine coole Physik am Plasma machen und sich irgendwie Gedanken über Materialien und Wahrbarkeit zu machen. Das ist...
Und trotzdem sind wir dazu verpflichtet, uns darüber Gedanken zu machen, weil wir sind zwar Grundlagenforscher, aber wir machen diese Grundlagenforschung, diese Ecke der Plasmaphysik, gucken wir uns ja an für ein bestimmtes Ziel. Und dieses Ziel dürfen wir auch nicht aus den Augen verlieren. Und die Umsetzbarkeit dieses Zieles ist die Begründung dafür, dass wir hier diese Physik machen können, machen überhaupt. Sonst wäre es ja total sinnlosig, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Die braucht ja sonst kein Mensch. Die hat ja nicht mal einen, irgendwie, ja weiß ich nicht nochmal, einen anderen Anspruch der besonderen Schönheit oder sowas. Da könnte man noch andere Dinge tun. Insofern ist es schon eine zielgerichtete Forschung, die wir hier machen. Und diese, mit dieser zielausrichtung gibt es eben diese starke technologische Komponente, mit der wir uns ständig auch aufeinandersetzen müssen. Das tun wir auch, dem stellen wir uns in verschiedenen Foren. So in dem weltweiten Konzert, da in dem weltweiten Gefüge. Da gibt es eben auch die stärker ausgerichteten technologischen Aktivitäten, mit denen die Physik dann immer wieder verbunden ist. Wir als Institut sind natürlich jetzt sehr stark auf die Physik ausgerichtet. Unsere Technologie-Kompetenz kommt dadurch zustande, dass wir unseren Physikapparat als selber bauen mussten und dafür die entsprechende technische Kompetenz dann eben entwickeln mussten. Dann gibt es aber auch Institute, Institutionen, Einrichtungen, Arbeitsgruppen, die sich wirklich dediziert mit diesen Engineering, mit diesen Materialfragen, mit diesen Wartbarkeits- und Revisions- also Wartbarkeits- und Maintenance- Phasen dann auseinandersetzen. Also insgesamt ist das so ein weltweites Gebäude, wo auch die Aufgaben geteilt werden und wo die Kompetenzen aufgeteilt werden, das eng miteinander verflochten ist, sodass wir dann innerhalb dieses Gebäudes dann am Ende zu den glaubwürdigen Lösungen kommen.
Da muss ich aber schon noch ein paar fiese Fragen stellen. Nehmen wir mal an, wir wären jetzt so weit und könnten ein Kraftwerk bauen. Wie lange dauert denn der bau von dem Kraftwerk? Also, ich meine, wenn das hier 17 Jahre lang gedauert hat, dann ein reguläres Kraftwerk, dauert das dann genauso lange oder länger?
First of all, das dauert immer lange.
Ich frage jetzt halt, weil ich mir denke, ich tue jetzt mal als wäre ich irgendwie FDP-Politiker und sage, wir müssen hier irgendwie keine Solarkraft bauen, weil die Fusion wird uns retten oder so. Wir machen jetzt irgendwie, wie realistisch ist denn das? Also selbst wenn mir jetzt alles best case läuft, bis wann können wir denn überhaupt nicht nur ein Kraftwerk haben, sondern wir wollen ja dann substanziell Grundlast damit erzeugen. Bis wann, von welchem Horizont reden wir denn hier?
Also erst mal die 17 Jahre mal in der Perspektive.
Das ist natürlich vorhin so, deswegen frage ich ja.
Also das war ja sehr explorativ und auf viel Zeit haben wir auch mit Kreiseln verbunden, also mit Reiterationen verbracht. Das ist gar keine Frage. Das ist vielleicht auch nicht der allerbeste Maßstab, denn dafür war sehr wichtig, um die Thematik zu verstehen. Also insofern sind diese Jahre, die wir da reingesteckt haben, die sind alles andere als vergeben. Wenn man jetzt mal rein hypothetisch sagt, wenn man jetzt alles bekommen könnte, also jetzt alles klar ist, man hat ein adekates Design und würde jetzt einfach loslegen, ohne jede Beschenkung. Also ohne, dass man fünfmal fragen muss oder ohne, dass man eben halt alles nochmal immer wieder ausprobieren muss, wenn ich jetzt alles auf den Tisch lege. Dann wären es die normalen bauzeiten für eine Großanlage.
So was wie dreieinhalb, vier Jahre oder sowas.
Man könnte sowas, wenn man richtig auf die baukarten fünf Jahre auf die Beine stellt, nicht der festen Überzeugung. Also wenn wir jetzt so ein Industriekonsertium zusammenstellen würden, aus richtig guten Industriepartnern.
Und es einen Design gibt.
Also ein fertigungsoptimiertes Design.
Sozusagen. Also dass die Sache dann so gut man es weiß, nicht so. Ein Design ist immer nur so gut, wie man es weiß. Und dass es fertigungsoptimiert ist, dass es so durchdacht ist, nicht wie ist das wirklich montagefreundlich, wie ist das baufertigungsfreundlich, nicht von A bis Z einmal durchgekaut, die ganze Angelegenheit. Dann die adäquate Organisation, die adäquaten Kompetenzen, die etwa in der Großindustrie sind, könnte man es aufbauen wie eine normale Großanlage. Denn das Prinzip ist das, also auch wenn ich mir dieses Ding da anschaue, ist das ganz normaler anlagenbau. Also das ist nichts besonderes, hat auch unser Montagechef. Das ist alles Industriestandard.
Sieht aber nicht normal aus, wenn ich so sagen darf.
Sieht relativ anormal aus, nicht so klar. Und das liegt aber daran, dass die Integrationsdichte einfach so krass hoch ist, wie die Integrationsdichte. Das heißt, Anzahl von Zeug pro Kubikmeter, nicht? Das ist das schöne Wort dafür, ist Integationsdichte. Die ist so extrem hoch, A, weil es eine Forschungsmaschine ist und B, weil wir uns auch ein bisschen verbastelt haben. Also das heißt, da sind auch viele...
Zugänglichkeiten und sowas.
Ja, das heißt, da sind auch... Am Ende haben wir uns auch manchmal in uns selber verwickelt. Wir sind in Silberna nicht mehr rausgekommen. Das sind so die typischen Prototypen-Dinge. Und das kann man natürlich im Prinzip alles abschmeißen, auch den ganzen Forschungsversieg abschmeißen. Das heißt, diese Anlage, die ist ja viel, viel komplizierter als ein künftiges Kraftwerk wäre. Ein künftiges Kraftwerk ist in dem Sinne wieder komplizierter, weil es A größer ist. Man muss mit größeren Komponenten umgehen. Das stört aber Ingenieure gar nicht so sehr. Die fragen, wie groß muss der Kran sein? Also habe ich auch mit unserem Montagechef mal gesprochen. Da hat gesagt, Moment, wir brauchen mindestens einen 10.000 Tonnen Kran. Da haben wir mal kurz im Netz geguckt, okay, man kann einen 40.000 Tonnen Kran in Korea bestellen. Ein paar Katalogs. Also da ist sogar Marge drin. Kein Problem. Also die Skalierbarkeit zu großen Komponenten, die ist da. Das ist ingenieurtechnisch hinzubekommen. Was eben ein schwieriger zusätzlicher Aspekt ist, ist die Nuklearanlage. Also die Nuklearanlagen müssen anders gebaut werden, natürlich. Und da hat man ganz andere gesetzliche Randbedingungen. Daran wird jetzt auch schon geschraubt, die jetzt mal anzupassen. Weil die gesetzlichen Rahmenbedingungen, die sind sehr stark inspiriert, eben einfach von der Kernspaltung. Und das Gefährdungspotenzial der Kernspaltung ist ja ein ganz anderes. Und deshalb sind die Gesetze auch darauf ausgelegt. Die sind zu streng. Großbritannien arbeitet gerade an einer neuen Gesetzgebung, USA arbeitet an einer neuen Gesetzgebung, die auf die Fusion zugeschnitten ist. Und das könnten schon mal so Muster sein, auch für den Rest der Welt.
Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt mal so ein bisschen in die Wünschdevers Zukunft guckt, dann würde man jetzt als nächstes nach der Alfa-Anlage hier mal eine Beta-Anlage bauen, um mal zu gucken, wie man halt eine Produktionsanlage macht, und dann einen ersten Produktionsprototypen bauen soll.
genau so.
Begleitet, wenn man beliebig viel Geld hat, natürlich immer von weiteren Forschungsanlagen, die diesen Anlagen dann zuarbeiten. Die bestimmte Aspekte, die sich dann erst beim bau herausgestellt haben, man dann wissenschaftlich auch mit den nötigen Instrumenten dann auch begutachten und verbessern kann. Aber ja, eigentlich...
Also wir sind jetzt sozusagen noch zwei Iterationen von einer ersten Produktionsanlage entfernt, und wie lange die, also wie viele Jahrzehnte zwischen den Iterationen sind, hängt eigentlich primär vom Geld ab und ein bisschen Glück.
Und auch Willen, ja, klar.
Na gut, aber damit kann man doch grob überschlagen, was sowas kostet, oder? Was hat denn dieses finnische Kraftwerk, Kernkraftwerk gekostet, was die da gerade...
15 Maljahren, glaube ich.
Das war ziemlich teuer, ja, aber das ist... Gut, also da... Wir sind ja hier gerade in einer Fantasiewelt, wo irgendwie das Budget nicht übersprungen wird. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus...
Wir rechnen einfach immer in...
Wie viel Kohle muss der Habeck locker machen, damit er nicht weitere irgendwie Flüssiggasturbinals baut, sondern jetzt mal Fusionen? Das ist doch die Frage hier, oder? Und was ich gerne noch mal ausgesprochen haben würde, ist, dass wir nicht aufhören können, Solar zu bauen, weil irgendwann Fusion kommt. Weil das gibt Leute, die denken das. Das ist... Ja.
Nee, wir müssen nur anfangen, Speicher zu bauen. Das ist eigentlich ein Problem. Aber gut, da haben wir noch eine andere Sinnung drüber.
Thema Speicher ist natürlich auch wieder ein großer Block. Das ist ungefähr so schwierig wie Fusion. Aber trotzdem, trotzdem... Also...
Was?
Ich dachte, Speichern ist ganz einfach. Irgendwie Wasser hochpumpen.
Wenn man genug Wasser hat, dann klar.
Also wenn wir bereit sind, ganz Norwegen zu verschwemmen, ja, könnten wir da wahrscheinlich genug speichern für uns. Aber ich glaube, das finde Norwegen nicht so gut.
Gibt es da Konzepte aus der Plasmaphysik?
Zum Beispiel Energiespeichern? Nee, können wir leider nicht bieten.
Mist, doch.
Also, das würde ich kurz warm machen gehen.
Also wir haben zu einem, in unserem Standort in Garcheng, so eine kleine Aktivität, so Power to Gas, nicht solche Sachen. Also Hilfe von Plasma, Katalysen. Also Plasma-gestützte Katalyse, das voranzubringen ist aber ein anderes Thema noch. Das steht natürlich in Konkurrenz zu der chemischen Katalyse. Da muss man ja wieder zeigen, dass eine Plasma-Assistent, also Plasma-gestützte Katalyse, dass die besser ist, also noch effizienter ist als die chemische Katalyse. Arbeiten ein bisschen dran an der Ecke.
Sieht das denn so aus oder ist das eher so, mal gucken?
Ist noch sehr am Anfang, oder?
Das ist ziemlich am Anfang, aber ist ein heißes Thema. Ja, da arbeiten also viele dran. Also Niederlande ist da ganz groß, die Fölle in den Niederlanden. Und da kann Plasmaphysik auch helfen, aber das ist Niedertemperaturplasmaphysik. Das ist noch mal eine andere, andere sehr wichtige Ecke der Plasmaphysik. Aber ist jetzt auch gar nicht mal so sehr unsere hauptlinie. Also wenn wir jetzt bei der Anwendung des Plasmas als tatsächlich so als Energiekonversion, so als Primärenergiequelle sind, dann muss man diesen Großanlagenweg gehen. Dabei ist die maus dann kein Faden ab.
Ich sehe hier aber nur die Nullen am Ende mehr werden.
Wir rechnen solche Technologien einfach immer in F35. Das ist eine handliche Einheit so. Und dann sind, keine Ahnung, was bräuchte, 20, 25 Milliarden oder so was, ja doch eher überschaubar.
Das sind ja gerade 100 Milliarden frei geworden.
Im Ende wahrscheinlich ist, wenn man wirklich mal so eine Zahl nimmt für ein first of a kind, ein wichtiges Kraftwerk, 20 Milliarden, keine falsche Zahl. Aber das ist first of a kind. Und dann geht die Sache runter.
Aber es kann auch sein, dass rauskommt beim first of a kind, dass das der falsche Ansatz war. Das ist halt das Problem.
Also das ist genau das Thema Risiko. Aber wenn man risikoscheu ist, also man sagt, ich will auf keinen Fall ein Risiko eingehen, dann muss man halt warten. Also entweder oder. Also wir arbeiten ja an der Risikoreduktion, in der wir uns immer weiter den Einzelaspekten vorarbeiten und immer breitere Businessbasis herstellen, um Risiko zu reduzieren. Und dieses sich vorarbeiten, das kostet eben Zeit. Und dann kriegt man das Risiko runtergebrückt. Wenn man die Zeit sich nicht nehmen will, muss man mehr Risiko nehmen. Also ein Wünsch-dir-was aus beiden, nicht so jetzt ganz schnell, aber kein Risiko, das gibt es nicht.
Eine Frage, die wir noch hatten von den Hörern, wie sieht denn eigentlich so der Alltag von einem Plasmaforscher, einer Plasmaforscherin hier in so einem System aus?
Vielfältig tatsächlich. Also ich arbeite als Plasmadiagnostiker in der Turbulenzforschung. Das heißt, ich gucke mir Plasmaturbulenz am Objekt, also an WCMX an. Meine Arbeit über die letzten Jahre war dann viel bau, also tatsächlich viel Engineering, Physics, viel auch Risikoabschätzung, also alles, was wir bisher so besprochen hatten, Wärmelasten und so weiter, also zum Teil auch super schnödes Zeug, was für mich anstrengend und langweilig ist. Aber dann letztendlich auch Diagnostikentwicklung, das heißt auch Modellierung von dem, was ich dann mit meinem System sehen möchte und Anpassung von meinem System, um diesen Parameterbereich dann auch abdecken zu können. Das heißt dann Rechnung, Simulation. Dann vor allem auch den einbau, der auch für mich dann persönlich auch super spannend ist. Also in der Maschine rumzuturnen, macht schon auch Spaß.
Also schraubst du denn da selber oder hast du das?
Ich hab's tatsächlich, also mein eigenes Projekt hab ich händesstark reingeschraubt. Da durfte ich natürlich nicht einfach so, sondern in klare Abstimmung und nach Montageplanen und mit dem von unseren Ingenieuren bestimmten Drehmoment für die schrauben zum Beispiel. Also es ist nichts dem Zufall überlassen. Aber am Ende durfte ich tatsächlich selber meine, also ich hab da eine Gastüse eingebaut, selber einbauen. Das ist schon ein Highlight, dann da so drumrum zu stehen und rumzulaufen. genau, bis hin dann zum Betrieb dieser Diagnostiken. Das heißt, wir sitzen hier direkt neben dem kontrollraum. Das heißt, wir verbringen dann viele anstrengende Wochen in diesem raum, fahren die Experimente, die wir davor in einem ziemlich langwierigen Prozess, also in so einem Proposal-Prozess dann die Experimente erarbeitet haben und quasi vorbereitet und hervorprogrammiert haben, wie sie dann durchlaufen sollen, also welche Heizszenarien, welche Dichten, welche Spulenparameter sollen an gegebenen Tag dann letztendlich abgefahren werden. Das wird alles aufeinander abgestimmt und ist auch meistens ein sehr überbestimmtes System. Also man hat tausende von Ideen und Einzelproposals, die halt von hunderten von Leuten kommen, die dann am Ende irgendwie zusammengeschrumpft werden müssen auf ein experimentales Programm, was dann im Zweifel dann sehr, sehr ambitioniert ist, weil es tausend Fragen auf einmal beantworten möchte.
Und die werden dann halt, wenn ihr den Betrieb habt, quasi beantwortet?
Also da fahren wir die Experimente, wie sie geplant sind. Oft sieht man gleich, dass Dinge nicht klappen. Meistens sieht man gleich, dass die Dinge nicht klappen. Oft sieht man auch ein positives Ergebnis, aber das publizierbare Endergebnis, sage ich mal, das ist dann immer noch ein Wochen- bis monatelanger Prozess, der sich dann an die Experimentkampagne anschließt, wenn man endlich auch mal ein bisschen Zeit hat, sich die Daten dann auch einfach anzugucken, die Modelle zu entwickeln, die Simulation noch mal durchlaufen zu lassen. genau, und da stecken wir jetzt gerade. Wir haben jetzt im März unsere letzte Experimentkampagne beendet. Seitdem wärmt die Maschine auf, damit ist für mich als Diagnostiker auch viel noch nach Kalibrierungsarbeit. Heute war ich auch wieder in der Halle und hab z.B. meinen einen Laser ausgebaut, der muss zur Wartung eingeschickt werden. Also so viel technisches, administratives Zeug, aber gleichzeitig gucke ich mir die Daten aus der letzten Kampagne an. Gerade auch in Vorbereitung auf die nächste Kampagne, die dann ab Dezember dann auch gleich schon wieder losgeht. Und im Dezember machen wir die Maschine wieder zu. Und das klingt jetzt als wäre da noch ein bisschen Zeit hin, aber wir müssen dann unsere ganzen Systeme dann für den Betrieb auch wieder vorbereiten. Das heißt, ab Oktober bin ich da wieder mit der Maschine ausgelastet. Das heißt, mir bleiben jetzt die paar Monate, wo ich dann auch noch zwei Konferenzen fahren will. Und Paper schreiben muss man auch.
Wie sieht denn das aus? Das klingt jetzt als wenn es eigentlich mehr Plasmaphysiker gibt, als es hier Plätze gibt, um Experimente zu fahren. Sollen wir überhaupt Werbung machen, dass Leute da kommen? Oder seid ihr eigentlich überbelastet?
Oder braucht ihr lieber mehr Ingenieure?
Wir haben eigentlich nie genug Leute. Ich habe beliebig viele Projekte. Ich habe eine To-do-Liste, die ich einmal im Jahr archiviere, weil es ja einfach überläuft. Mit kleinen Projekten für Studentinnen und Studenten. Zu tun gibt es immer. Und langweilig wird uns auf jeden Fall nicht.
Es ist ja auch so ganz zyklisch. Wir sind jetzt in einen neuen Modus operan, die eingetreten. Wir waren ja nur wirklich die berühmten 17 Jahre lang. Also auf jeden Fall überwiegend waren wir dann eine baustelle, wo wir maschinenbau gemacht haben, anlagenbau gemacht haben, wo alles von der baustelle demoniert war und alles drehte sich um die baustelle herum. Und unser wissenschaftliches Personal war auch auf der baustelle. Die haben halt die wissenschaftlichen Instrumente gebaut und entwickelt. Und jetzt schwenken wir gerade in so einen Modus rein, wo wir jetzt die nächsten zehn Jahre immer so einen Zyklus haben, Betrieb, Downzeit. Nicht also das heißt also Betriebszeit, Downzeit. In der Downzeit wird die Wartung der Maschine gemacht, werden kleine Reparaturen, ein paar Erweiterungen gemacht und dann wieder Betrieb und dann wieder Downzeit. Das bedeutet eben für die Forschenden, dass während des Betriebes sammelt man Daten, eben nach einem wohl überlegten Plan, nach einem ausbaldoverten Plan, wo man sich genau festlegt, was für Experimente führt man durch, also welche Art sind diese Daten. Das heißt, man fährt diese Daten ein, hat fast keine Zeit, sich mit diesen Daten zu beschäftigen während der Zeit. Weil dann ist gleich der nächste Tag, da kommt der nächste Run und so was, dann werden Daten produziert, produziert, produziert. Und in der Downzeit hat man ein bisschen Luft, sich überhaupt mal mit den Daten zu beschäftigen. Also sozusagen wie Ernte und Strohdreschen. Und dann wieder Ernte und Strohdreschen.
Also eigentlich braucht ihr Leute, die beim datenauswerten helfen.
Eigentlich bei allem. Also auch allein schon die Wartung von den Diagnostäcken. Und da habe ich gerne auch Praktikanten, die mir einfach helfen, weiß nicht, einen optischen Tisch zusammen zu basteln und eine Kalibration zusammenzumachen und so. Also es gibt quasi große Vielfalt an Aufgaben, für die wir eigentlich so ein bisschen, wo ich schon überlastet bin, einfach erst alles unterzubringen. Und was Thomas Gade sagte, diesen Zyklus von regelmäßigen Betrieb, den haben wir halt noch nicht. Wir haben jetzt gerade unsere erste Kampagne im vollausbau der Maschine gehabt. Davor waren drei Jahre pause, wo wir viel Zeit hatten, von denen wir bestimmt auch zum Teil ein bisschen den falschen Fokus gesetzt haben, weil wir vielleicht auch zum Teil zu ambitioniert waren in dem ausbau unserer Messsysteme. genau. Und jetzt werden wir gezwungen, mehr oder weniger uns daran zu gewöhnen, dass es jedes Jahr einen Betrieb geben wird und wir nur die Zeit dazwischen haben, uns zu beschäftigen, was wir denn eigentlich gemacht haben. Das setzt natürlich auch einen ganz anderen Rahmen. Also man hat halt nicht mehrere Jahre Zeit, um sich irgendwie was ganz Neues zu überlegen und oh, wär's nicht cool, wenn wir mal das machen, sondern wir müssen uns jetzt halt auf nötige beschränken und sagen, das sind wirklich die wichtigen Themen und das sind jetzt auch die wichtigen Maschinenupgrades, die uns dann auch wirklich weiterbringen.
Also die jetzt so beim Betrieb, also wenn jetzt so gucken, ihr habt jetzt macht das ein paar Wochen Betrieb und dann macht ihr ein paar Monate Wartung. Was geht da so kaputt? Also was sind so die, so alles mögliche?
Na, Wartung muss ja nicht mehr bedeuten, dass gleich was kaputt ist.
Oder was ausgetauscht werden muss, oder?
Na, es gibt immer in der Tat so die Routine-Wartung, die gemacht werden müssen an ganzen technischen Anlagen. Pumpen, Klassiker.
Das ist alles Vakuum und so, ja.
Nicht Wasserpumpen, Vakuumpumpen, Hochspannungsanlagen, elektrische Anlagen. Nicht da haben wir einfach einen regelmäßigen Wartungszyklus für den Investitionserhalt, damit das Zeug nicht einfach vergammelt und dann immer unzuverlässiger wird, nicht nach dem Ende ersetzt werden muss. Dafür muss man die Anlagen ran, die müssen dafür aus der Betrieb genommen werden, die müssen dafür teilweise ausgebaut, eingeschickt werden. Nicht Stichwort Laser oder so was. Das ist ein Zeug, das ist auch nicht vielfältig. Das ist die Erhaltung der technischen Anlage. Ja, und dann gehen Sachen auch kaputt während der Experimente. Da passieren Dinge.
Physik mit großen Kräften.
Ja, wie auch immer. Ja, es passieren verschiedene Dinge. Manches kann man eben während des laufes reparieren. Manchmal muss man sagen, das machen wir dann später. Also entweder weil man auch nicht rankommt. Also gerade wenn es im Gefäß ist, dann eh nicht. Aber auch schon in der Halle, während der Maschinenbetrieb ist, ist die Halle personenfrei. Da kann man dann nicht drin rumlaufen, halt dann wirklich nur die Nachtstunden. Da kann man nicht viel machen. Wir müssen also viel einfach so in den Skatbrücken immer sagen, okay, das bringen wir später. Die Längeliste wird immer länger, das kriegen wir später, das bringen wir später in Ordnung. Und dann muss einfach auch alles gemacht werden. Und dann erweist sich auch während des Betriebes, erweisen sich manche Sachen einfach auch als blöd oder falsch gemacht. Das heißt also, dass wir Fehler eingebaut haben oder dass wir sie schlecht gemacht haben. Dann müssen wir sie besser machen. Dann müssen wir es in Ordnung bringen. Da muss das erweitert werden, verbessert werden, repariert werden. Nicht, weil man es einfach falsch gemacht hat, Sachen falsch verdrahtet hat. Weißt du, guck, guck, was denn das funktioniert denn nicht? Und da kann man sich vorher tot testen. Man findet das erst raus, wenn man das als Gesamtsystem laufen. Also wir haben da ganz viele Überraschungen erlebt von lauter getesteten Einzelsystemen, die im Gesamtzusammenspiel gar nicht mehr so gut gehen.
Und das ist auch echt anstrengend, also das knirscht dann auch. Wir hatten das gerade zu Beginn dieser Kampagne, die deswegen auch besonders frustrierend war, weil wir ja schon mal damals in der Kampagne kurz nachdem ihr gekommen seid, wir hatten ja schon mal eine funktionierende Maschine. Und es klingt dann so, wenn man halt nur mal ein paar Kühlwasserkreißläufer umbaut, dass es dann ja eigentlich genauso wieder weiterlaufen sollte. Aber das ist natürlich nicht so. Jeder hat irgendwie an seinem System was verbessert, vielleicht in Anführungsstrichen, oder auch was anders gemacht, oder selbst auf ein anderes Betriebssystem irgendwie seine Steuersoftware umgebaut. Und man merkt das dann erst, wenn man dann plötzlich im Betrieb dann da steht und merkt, der Rechner geht nicht an und ich komm da nicht hin, weil der in der Halle ist. Also ganz schnöde Sachen. Und erst wenn alles wirklich zusammenkommt und man vor dem Problem steht, heute gehen die Experimente los und mein System funktioniert nicht, merkt man halt, wie unglaublich verschränkt und komplex alles ist. Und das wird dann, glaube ich, auch besser, wenn wir in regelmäßigen Betrieb gehen und wir einfach wissen, was man auch nicht anfasst am besten. Ja, aber das ist eine sehr steile Lernerfahrung. Und die ganze Integration und das Zusammenspiel von vielen verschiedenen Systemen und Komponenten ist schon doll. Wir haben ja zum Beispiel für den Plasma-Betrieb, für den seheren Plasma-Betrieb sehr viele verschiedene Systeme, die alle gleichzeitig funktionieren müssen. Zum Beispiel dürfen wir nicht einfach Leistung reinfeuern in das leere Experiment, wenn keine Plasmadichte da ist. Das heißt, wir haben eine Diagnostik, eine komplexe Plasmadiagnostik, die ein Live-Signal liefern muss, die uns immer sagt, wie hoch die Dichte zum gegebenen Zeitpunkt ist. Die ist halt an die Sicherheitskomponente angeschlossen. Die muss innerhalb von ein paar Millisekunden immer ein konstantes Signal liefern und halt auch über diese sehr langen Zeiten, das heißt über mehrere Minuten, muss sie das zufälligstig tun. Wenn das Signal wegfällt, wird sofort die Heizung ausgeschaltet, weil dann unser Sicherheitssystem nicht weiß, ob überhaupt noch Plasma da ist. Und das ist nur ein Beispiel von vielen, von allen möglichen Temperatursensoren, die halt anschlagen können. Und das sind alles Dinge, die einzeln irgendwie getestet sind. Aber wo man dann erst im kompletten Zusammenspiel merkt, dass es manchmal auch so richtige Lockup-Situationen gibt, wo man merkt, wir können das extra mal so gar nicht fahren, weil ja irgendwie das Sicherheitssystem da immer an der einen Stelle eingreift, weil wir diesen Fall gar nicht vorher gesehen haben. Und gerade, weil es eine Experimental-Anlage ist, weil wir Physiker uns immer völlig abgefahrene Betriebsszenarien ausdenken, wo unsere Sicherheitsingenieure sagen, warum eigentlich überhaupt, ist das für alle Seiten oft ziemlich challenging und man gerät da manchmal. Man wird da manchmal auch ärgerlich und das knirscht auch oft, wenn man dann irgendwie aneinander gerät und natürlich die Maschinen-Sicherheit dann vorgeht und wir als Physiker aber auf der anderen Seite überzeugt sind, das geht schon, das kann man machen, aber am Ende, man will halt ambitioniert, aber gleichzeitig konservativ mit der Maschine sein und das ist zum Teil schwierig.
Also diese Down-Zeit, die brauchen wir dringend, außer so zum Wunden lecken. Aber es wird jetzt ein regelmäßiger Zyklus werden und das wird auch helfen, also das wird über die Zeit auch helfen, weil es kommt mehr Routine rein. Denn das ist ja auch ein neues Team, ein junges Team, was fantastisch ist, weil da viel Kreativität und viel Begeisterung für die Sache drin ist. Also wenig so Routine-Forschung, würde ich so sagen, das ist schon toll. Aber natürlich ist man da nicht so trittfest, als wenn man das schon zehn Jahre lang gemacht hat. Also deshalb sind wir jetzt auch in so einem Trainingsprozess so drin, in so einem Teamformierungsprozess.
Ja, aber das ist doch, um nicht zu sagen, die primäre Aufgabe, dass man die Erfahrungen sammelt, das ist dann kaputt gehen. Ja, und wie reparieren wir das dann?
Ja, aber es ist auch nervig.
Na ja, natürlich. Aber lieber jetzt hier einmal im Prototyp, als in zehn Kraftwerken, die wir irgendwo hingebaut haben.
Ja, also deshalb diese Plattitüde, die ich von gebracht habe, man lernt nur Maschinen zu bauen, die man Maschinen baut, das kann man auch auf das Betreiben ausweiten.
Ja gut, also ich bin mit meiner Fragenliste durch. Weißt du noch was?
Ne, hab ich auch.
Habt ihr noch was, was ihr noch anmerken wollt für unsere Hörer?
Unbedingt loswerden wollen. Wird nochmal was unbedingt los.
Ein Aufruf an Bill Gates, der vor mal 20 Milliarden abwärmt.
Na ja, beziehungsweise gut, wir haben ja jetzt in Deutschland auch die Agentur für Sprunginnovationen, die jetzt auch.
Ja, na ja, ich glaube, es ist einfach auch, es fehlt im Moment noch so ein bisschen. Die Ansage fehlte, glaube ich, dass wenn wir wollten, könnten wir losbauen. Wenn man das nicht gehört hat, dann gibt es die Badezweig auch nicht.
Also wir bereiten uns da ja auch strategisch drauf vor. Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir und wir auf unseren Anlagen rumsitzen und sagen, das machen wir jetzt die nächsten 20 Jahre, sondern wir rechnen ja optimistisch mit dem Fall, dass es irgendwann auch Geld gibt und bereiten dann auf, also haben verschiedene Ideen, was man, wenn einmal Geld da sein sollte, im großen Maßstab auch alleine für unsere Instituten, was man damit Cooles machen könnte. Wir werden jetzt nicht total überrascht davon, wenn jetzt ein großes Paket persönlich ankommt.
Ich glaube, so funktioniert das nicht. Man muss nur irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass das ankommt. Dann kann man einfach sagen, okay, das ist doch eine Sache, wo Habeck und Lindner irgendwie in eine Richtung gehen. Irgendwann sagt, wir haben Fusion und es hilft gegen die Klimakrise. Da könnte sich doch einige über 20 Milliarden los eisen.
Also es wäre ein super Ding. Also ich bin ein großer Fan davon, dass Deutschland das einfach mal machen soll. Einfach mal das Risiko, also dieses Kapitalrisiko eingehen und das einfach mal probieren. Selbst wenn es nicht fliegt, dann ist man einen gewaltigen Schritt vorangekommen, dann fliegt es im nächsten Schritt. Ich bin der Überzeugung, das wird funktionieren. Die Diffusion wird funktionieren, sie wird kommen. Sie wird früher oder später kommen. Und wie früh sie kommt, das ist eher ein Willensakt.
Wie groß wäre der Beschleunigungsfaktor, wenn ihr sagen würdet, okay, ihr müsstet jetzt nicht nach haushaltsrecht, Vergaberecht arbeiten, sondern die Sprint kann euch das Geld einfach mal...
Jetzt wird es aber Sci-Fi.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Moment. Die Sprint hat gerade tatsächlich ein Gesetz durchbekommen, dass sie aus dem Vergaberecht rauskommt. Ja, ja, da hat jemand mal verstanden. Also wir halt doch ein bisschen schneller agieren müssen. Wie groß wäre der gefühlte Beschleunigungsfaktor?
Gefühlt wahrscheinlich Faktor 2.
Wow. Krass. Okay.
Also eben, der ist uns umzingelnde Regelwerk mit gefühlten Faktor 2. Und ich glaube, das Gefühl ist nicht ganz falsch.
Okay. Tja, dann müssen wir vielleicht noch mal...
Wir lassen es noch mal ein paar Leute anrufen. Na gut, also wir tun gerne unseren Teil, um euch hier ein paar neue Praktikanten vorbeizuschießen. Mal sehen, ob wir 20 Milliarden Losgeist kriegen. Da will ich jetzt noch keine Zusagen machen, aber schön wär's.
Auf der nächsten Sendung dann.
genau.
Also wer sich hierfür begeistern kann, der kann da mit uns gerne in Kontakt kommen. Und wir werden immer sehen, was so geht. Natürlich können wir auch nicht geliebig Personal hier so plötzlich eintüten und muss sich schon auch ein bisschen einarbeiten und muss auch schon ein bisschen was mitbringen dann dabei.
Wir haben ja viele sehr junge Menschen, die uns hören und die überlegen, was sie mit ihrem Leben machen und die auch überlegen, was sie jetzt studieren sollen und irgendwie auch uns auch fragen, was sind jetzt eigentlich so Gebiete, wo ich mich drauf fokussieren kann, wenn ich bestimmte Talente habe, wo ich nicht das Gefühl habe, ich verschwende jetzt mein Leben so.
Und hier kann ich auch die Welt retten.
Ja genau, ich verschwende mein Leben nicht. Das ist ja der wichtige Punkt dabei.
Ja, also schon die die Studenten, aber auch die viele von unseren jungen Ingenieure und Techniker, die wollen alle die Welt retten. Die kommen hier, um die Welt zu retten. Also die können noch andere Sachen machen.
Und das ist der richtige Ort dafür. Das können wir vielleicht auch noch mal explizit ansagen.
Und immer auch die Studenten hier an der Uni Greifswald. Also sehr viele kommen hier explizit hierher, um genau das hier zu machen.
Also auch so maschinenbauer und so?
Nee, also Technik, also Technik-Universität sind wir ja nicht. Und da muss man dann über eine technische Universität, TU Berlin oder Aachen oder Rostock, nicht? Denn da gehen aber immer, wenn man Physik machen will, von den Physik-Studenten sind sehr, sehr viele, die kommen explizit wegen der Fusion hierher und machen das auch und machen das auch mit Feuereifer und mit allem, was in ihnen drinsteckt. Das ist definitiv etwas, was auch sehr hohe für diese Universität auch sehr hohe Sichtbarkeit hat. Denn dieses Ding gibt es ja nur hier. Obendrein ist es das Beste der Welt mit verlaub.
Ja, das freut uns, haben wir vielleicht ein oder zwei von beigetragen.
Und natürlich als niederschwelligeres Angebot. Man kann natürlich immer für Besucherführung hier vorbeikommen. Das ist auch ein großer Teil unseres Geschäfts. Wir nehmen es auch ernst, dass wir einen bildungsauftrag haben und Leute einfach gucken können. Und das, was ihr gestern gemacht habt, das heißt, um wirklich in die Halle zu gehen, das Ding einfach zu sehen, wie es aussieht. Und dass man auch hier gleich in der Ostsee das Ausflugzeug macht.
Das kann man auch nicht deutlich genug sagen. Jede und jede ist hier herzlich willkommen. Das ist ein offenes Institut. Man kann sich einfach bei unserem Besucherdienst anmelden. Und dann kann man sich den ganzen Kram angucken. Man kriegt sogar noch einen schicken Vortrag von so einem Radiant-Typ-artigen. Nicht unbedingt nur er selber, dann hätte er nichts anderes mehr zu tun. Also wir haben dann ein ganzes Bündel. Aber das ist nicht hinter einem zaun versteckt.
Sehr schön. Ja, dann herzlichen Dank. Das war extrem interessant.
Und viel Erfolg. Ihr müsst uns finden.
genau. Und in sieben Jahren gucken wir vorbei und gucken, ob wir dann endlich mal gezündet haben.
Wir haben ja angefangen, so ein bisschen nachzugucken.
Unser Plasma zünden wir ja da.
Plasma, war ich mal.
Ja, aber Fusion zünden wir nie. Dafür sind wir ja gar nicht ausgelegt.
genau, deswegen sieben Jahre, 20 Milliarden.
genau, also in dem Sinne die Anlage da auf dem Feld gegenüber.
Ja, genau.
Man muss die Ziele ja immer ambitioniert setzen.
Wo noch das Feld ist. Aber wichtig ist, wir brauchen einen Hafen. Also für die schweren Komponenten ist ein Hafen wichtig. Also Logmin wäre eigentlich das Ding.
Verstehe. Ja, dann.
Das ist kein Problem.
Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Und dann, bis zum...
Wir danken fürs Gespräch.
Gerne wird's.
Dann bis zum nächsten Mal.